the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody we are once more in
the central west end here the heart of
american chess at the st louis chess
club it's true the american cup 2022 is
finished we do have the winners of that
event but we have a little bit more
chats for you we have rapid fast and
furious blitz chess coming your way and
to bring you the action for that i am
grand master alejandro ramirez here with
the legend himself grand master yes sir
sarah won as always alejandro a pleasure
to be here with you hello everyone and
welcome to fast and furious blitz action
as we have nine rounds for you but first
let's review the two winners of the
american cup starting with absolutely
fabiano carona proved dominant through
the event he had a little bit of a shaky
start there against jeffrey showing
survived a couple of games against sam
savion but after that it was smooth
sailing for this player
showing why he is a candidate showing
why he's so strong at classical chess
didn't lose a single life in this double
elimination and first place goes as well
as 50 000 price and the ten thousand
dollar bonus to fabiano caruana
meanwhile in the ladies section it was
the story of the wunderkind and another
player that simply demolished the field
irena crush was
in another level compared to the rest of
the field and she takes home a very well
deserved 25 thousand dollar first prize
any 5 000 bonus for winning through the
classical also not losing a live first
place arena crush dominant victory
but today it's all about blitz and let's
take a look at our format take it away
alejandro we start from zero blitz event
for you guys friday april 29th that's
today we've been looking this for quite
a while it's a 34 player swiss system
tournament of nine blitz rounds and the
blitz is fast and furious three plus two
and that's it
and christian you're with us to drill
down on this uh unique event the one of
the strongest if not the strongest
bullets
held in america christian good to see
you my friend always a pleasure to see
you guys and cast the games of this
amazing players we had a lot of fun
during the last couple of weeks with the
american cup and today is casual friday
we're going to be playing some fast and
furious blitz we're going to have a lot
of action a lot of decisive results and
i'm looking forward to see what these
players are going to be bringing to the
table but who are these players who is
in our tournament well we have all 16
players from the american cup none of
them flew back to home to their families
no no no they're here in st louis and
ready to compete one more time also we
have selected players title players from
saint louis university mizzou as well as
webster university also we have one
varusia nakobian our own broadcast team
member var is going to be cranking up
the action today we're going to have a
lot of fun guys thank you christian it
almost feels like st louis versus
america can't wait and what are they
playing for alejandro yeah we have
prizes for today's matches we have a 21
000
prize fund first second and third that's
what the top gm's are playing for but we
also have category prices under 2600
will have two prices under 2502 as well
under 24 out of two as well and these
are going to be the higher of your
ratings based on your frida standard or
your feed a blitz i got it whatever is
your highest rating that's your category
now because all of these games are going
to be going on we're going to be very
selective in our broadcast and we're
going to just be concentrating on the
top five boards so apologies
if your favorite player is playing on a
lower board each round because it's only
three minutes and two seconds per move
we can't see all the games but the top
five is where we'll be focused and you
can join the conversation too and ask us
which players you'd like us to focus on
as the players all getting around and
discussing
their strategies or maybe not definitely
not
juan fabiano caruana i spot ilya nishnik
a student a former student athlete
tony rich there is mr rich right there
executive director of the club getting
ready to welcome all the players and
again this is a 34 player
nine round swiss there's only nine
rounds of blitz action but it will go
quickly it'll it'll grow quite quickly
if you're wondering where that is it's
not our traditional playing hall as you
noticed no it's actually a little uh we
used to be a restaurant space is where
kingside diner used to be exactly
without all the remodel kingside diner
moved across the street and now we call
this side queenside i like that
[Laughter]
very very nice but it's a nice space and
and there's fabi we're gonna be watching
this game but the first seat of the
tournament is actually a certain wesley
so i would like to start with him
although i don't mind this matchup he's
going to be facing one of my students
nice jameel john alimarandi he is on his
sixth year at slu started a long time
ago it feels like a young 18 year old
player i was an international master
when he joined slu and now he's a
full-fledged grandmaster and he's
playing fabiano carmano with the white
pieces fantastic so once again wesley
soh
will be our highest rated blitz player
he'll start on board one lavon aronian
our second highest rated bullets player
will play on board two fabby on aboard
three and i think we actually have a sam
shanklin versus arena crush matchup on
board six so one of the top players of
the us olympic teams versus our america
cup winner it's a tough tournament where
you're a grandmaster and you get paired
up on a first round
it truly is what a bummer that is and
thabbe of course playing the black
pieces to start obviously when you have
an odd number of games
in a swiss you're going to get
an unequal number of colors somebody's
going to have five whites somebody's
going to have five blacks and there we
see wesley saw as well getting trying to
tournament is starting very shortly very
very shortly we have some crazy blitz
specialists that were perhaps not part
of the tournament but some of my
students all they do is play blitz i
mean they just log online they're on
chess.com leech us all day makes
coaching easy oh very easy
and
who
in from your
field of players from st louis
university who are you looking at and
saying go out there and get the first
prize actually um my strongest student
in this tournament is nicolas theodorou
i guess uh he's a blitz specialist for
sure he's part of the olympic team of
greece wow and he was instrumental to
winning the final four a few years ago
we won the national championship and he
beat actually a webster student by name
of benjamin gladura one of the top 94
players in the world yeah and for you uh
christian who who are your big guns
in at the field from mizzou i would say
is uh probably grand master gregory
oparin uh originally from russia now
studying here in the united states he i
would
call him a blitz or rather rapid time
control specialist as well actually he's
in a top 30 in terms of his rapid rating
and right now his top 50 classical as
well but his blitz rating well we
haven't seen this player play as much
blitz as other time controls so i'm
looking forward to see what he's going
to bring to the table
and there's wesley saw you can see him
at the end uh he's going to be playing
as nico we also see the match up here a
little bit closer to us sam sebian will
be starting against anna satonski it's
going to be a tough matchup for for
everybody there's no easy rounds here no
there is not and again tony rich just
welcoming the players the the man in the
red was mike cummer uh
arbiter here at the saint louis chess
club and he'll be doing the pairings and
we'll be trying to get the pairings to
you as quickly as possible
and then zoning in on what game we want
to look at yeah they're just going over
some of the final rules of the event
now you alejandro have won a numerous
blitz tournaments that have been staged
here in st louis at the st louis chess
club overall what's your strategy is
just to play good moves quickly as fast
as possible be practical any particular
strategies that you have used or would
recommend to these blitz players i think
there's a temptation uh of thinking in
bad positions and that's something you
need to avoid like if you feel your
position is bad make a move anyway yeah
play fast
play fast because you're not going to
make a better decision in a minute
you're just going to make the same
decision
but badly and you're going to feel
yourself in time travel i think three
plus two is a very tricky time control
uh i see a lot of people that blitz
because the increments can actually
work in your favor the increment adds up
pretty quickly when you get a good
position you can make a lot of moves in
a row
and by the way uh those clashes between
leveronian and ratca as well as
theodorus and wesley so we could
actually be seeing those at the olympiad
later this year we don't know exactly
who's going to be playing board one for
the united states but we know as you're
mentioning alejandro that nico is
playing for greece and most likely he
will be uh board one or two
i just saw a handshake and i looked for
a second light there that lavonne had
started his opponent's clock and they
are now underway and here we go three
plus two all right fast and furious
action so we're focusing on
i think we're assuming it on fabi's game
to start the fair enough i mean after
all he just did have a fine result in
the american copy he was our
winner
and uh he is black now tell me a little
bit uh more about burundi you were
saying
he's certainly one of the most improved
players at slu we had a lot of problems
on our fourth board actually the first
time we played the final four we scored
zero out of three oops and on this one
we scored two and a half out of three
all two and a half coming from jj so
he's certainly a specialist of the
london he's played this since he started
at slu really got a lot of good scopes
out of it and i think a lot of people
have also asked themselves how do you
get winning chances against the london
um
that's black right very very difficult
because it's a solid system
there might be some criticisms you could
try to play those queen b6 ideas and
bite the poison pawn on b2 but you're
risking quite a lot if you go for those
lines as well this one is definitely
much more tame the way fabiano is
playing right now we see uh bishop takes
g3 h takes g3 do you agree by the way uh
winning threat there
foreign for e4 e5 and uh bishop takes h7
was a winning threat knight c6 to stop
the move e4 e5 queen into reinforcing it
precisely
and now uh frankly yeah i like white
yeah
uh i really don't like that bishop takes
g3 by fabiano h7
h7h6
um
man you just want to play g4 and go get
them don't you maybe even lone castle
let's go for it that's jj's style both
long castle and g4 he might be a little
more sedate all right
sorry true true style you should always
be true to your style when you're by
such players exactly and regardless of
who they are maybe even if they're the
world's top player
uh castle's long and yeah well he's
basically signaling here i'm coming to
get you e4 e5 on tap
and uh do something quickly because g4
g5 will be another battering ram sorry
so what if i show uh a d4 right now is
that a move that i think it's certainly
either it's really a move i think you
just sidestep it c4 and then maybe i can
go for uh e5 block things up
bishop to e6 followed that might be just
a losing move dude before e5
d take c3 yes knight c4 like let's go
and it could just be checkmate on the
kings side yeah cause we need four
companies
that's right or rook h6 or something
like that and e5 okay all right now
knight takes e4 queen e4 you'd have to
go back with the knight but i think that
would be
okay this move indicates to me that
fabby is ready to move his key
in case it gets too hot to handle and by
the way e5 e4 potential threat that jj
will have to keep in mind i think it's
time for rook h4
look to h4 and what's the plan just
amazing it's just a good piece it's just
a good piece i think rook h4 is just
going to be met by f5 i think this is
the big threat that fabiano was getting
five five shots
that's my students oh
the training the training face off
they were paying attention they weren't
very surprisingly they seemed like they
were asleep but they were actually
let's go f5
no so we can see the clock the coaches
bishop c4 bishop b6 the clash of the
coaches taking place here this is a
proxy war everybody this is more vision
v6 put a rook under each one come on you
never know when taking on h6 is good but
actually there's a lot of tempting
options for voyager
i'd be more inclined maybe towards
knight b3 looks like
yeah getting ready to meet e4 with
knight d4 quite important exactly that's
exactly right now the dream of course is
to somehow get to play g4 g5 and break
open the king side but
how can you reinforce these threats guys
the problem with g4 is that it always
allows knight f4 with an
indication that something's gone wait
what happened a little bit of miss a
little bit yeah
absolutely
dividing knight h4
inviting knight h4 and tickling the pawn
on i like that five i like that h4 it's
such an uncomfortable move exactly
exactly
knight h4 probably we're going to see
something along the lines of a queen to
c8 maybe from fabio a little bit awkward
but yeah i can get behind that
too it doesn't seem like that's the
right direction well
there's a lot of problems on the
diagonal he just wants to get rid of
this knight on d5 so what if i continue
with e4 now go for it and we'll
oh
no knight d4 would leave the bishop on
c4 hanging e5 centralizing five and
threatening perhaps g5
i like that's an awkward threat
but now g5 is going to be met by knight
g6 good point
you can't take that's good
but the knight is kind of stuck isn't it
on
defending
no no i don't like that i thought knight
f3 and knight d4 well uh the because the
knight's now stranded on the h4 square
whereas i thought right f3
centralized the knight to d4 okay he's
done it the other way he's not afraid of
g5 well he's definitely
f5 square well oh he reached for his g1
but it only moved it one square
okay
again the desirable g3 g4 hangs the
knight on h4 and how are we doing on
time guys 30 33 seconds i guess the
minute
four fabby's played very swiftly
wow wow
i've never thought of abby as the
greatest blitz game blitz player but
he's really improved his rapids and
blitz skills now he's suddenly improved
his results he's become more practical
as a player okay and he just tilts less
tilts less i like that
rook
not a h
well he wants to play g4 and then he
didn't play g4 he really wants to play
g4 though
again the problem with g4 is always
knight takes f4
that is a
huge deal that he needs
well we're going for it good or bad
doesn't matter that's why he played
queen e1 at some point you just got to
implement your idea and g3 no takes e4
he's not worried about his king
he's not worried about his king on this
diagonal that is very brave i have to
say
9966 i don't see that coming
where does the queen go
well that's asking this alien question
on the road no it's attacked by the rook
on e8 correct knight takes f4 this is
which certainly is
it certainly is f1 setting up this rook
to f2 pin potential i'm thinking knight
takes d4 and possibly g6 g5
there is a bishop takes b3 sighting as
well
he's done it
takes b3
and now g5 no i mean he's keeping
this threat
in his pocket a little too long no bro
at some point yeah you lose it
when you don't use it
rook
f8 i like to get to first maybe i was
missing something knight takes g3 maybe
then takes f6 down to four seconds for
jj
versus 13 seconds 97 and thread
and ticking and then
he's seen it
he did see it but boy it took some time
now it's all about who's got the fast
which muscle one second there ooh really
yeah
knight takes f3 this is he cannot
check i cannot take twice that was a
mistake
knight takes g3 perhaps no just try the
queens right yeah yeah very solid indeed
knight takes g3 queen takes e4 knight
takes e4
okay now it's just two pawns this is too
easy now two connected pass pawns just
avoid the tricks oh
he's winning so we might want to switch
to that one he seems to be a couple of
pawns up now number one
perhaps uh christian can take it on his
board board number one there you see
wesley right now
very colorful that's probably not the
proper color of this shirt but i think
it's these under some
lights
i see a lot of black pawns and i have it
i have it on my board too and i don't
see a lot of white pawns
all black has to do is get the a pawn
moving right yeah that's it knight
three four four
he's happy to get his e pawn moving king
e4 knight f4 on wesley's agenda and then
he's just
pushing the e pawn home
very nice
alex wesley top six games that was the
last one to finish so everything else is
done i do have a victory
uh for sam shanklin this is irina
crush's first defeat
in two weeks well it comes with a hands
of a strong player sam shanklin
certainly the better blitz player at
least on paper and jeffrey jean
i want to say upset by his opponent in
the sense that jeffrey zhang played the
lower rated opponent who made a draw
with the white pieces jeffree zhang was
the only player on the top six board to
get nicked by their lower rated
opponents and
perhaps christian can take a look at
that because that is his student that is
indeed my student uh raja harshit from
india he's a freshman right now at the
university bishop to g5 we see this
french that we've seen from jeffrey in
his match against fabiano caruana as
well he's starting to repeat this one
and once again he gets close to losing
positions
typical jeffrey he loves to play the
french i'm not 100 sure why
i guess it's because it's easy moves for
black right you're going to put your pc
you know where you're going to put your
pieces you know that you're probably
going to get the worst position out of
the opening and then you're just going
to practically fight to get back into
the game so let's see how that happened
queen to b6 castle a very aggressive
approach by white trying to set up this
flank attack with g4 later on knight to
d7 g4 immediately better was potentially
knight to h6 to stop this idea of g4 and
we exchange a couple of pawns knight to
h6 white is going to open everything up
the avenues the h and g avenues going
towards the black king bishop to h3
knight to e7 rook to g1 bishop f8 and
now what black is trying to do with this
move bishop to f8 well first of all that
bishop on g7 was biting on granite on
this pawn on e5 as supported by the pawn
on d4 so what uh he wants to do is to go
to a3 potentially and create some sort
of an attack or perhaps exchange it with
bishop e7 so that finally i can get my
king to safety on the queen side bishop
to e7 bishop take c7 rook g7 and this
game actually got wild take take on c5
now we see rook to ca the king is going
to be stuck in the center for a while
you're not castling short you're not
castling long for sure rook to c8 queen
to g5 queen takes e5 attacking the pawn
on c2 c3 sidestepping that threat rook
to f8 rook to d4 knight to c6 rook to f4
d4
opening up the center but allowing
the big tactical blow bishop takes e6
which came on the board and wait how did
my student not know that
my goodness bishop to b3 returning the
favor instantaneously bishop takes f7
was just this way easily
winning after take take you take back
now i'm just going to continue taking in
fact discovered e6 this was the key
moment that my student raja missed
because right now this opens up the
fifth rank and the queen on c5 is going
to be lost he missed this one he played
bishop to b3 which allowed black to
regain control uh of the game at least
for equality queen 21 king to b2 queen
to d2 king to b1 queen to d3 and we saw
a perpetual in this game quite a tense
affair in the middle game and then it
just simply exploded for both sides very
very intriguing games guys thank you
thank you christian i was about to say
i'm embarrassed to say it's not a french
defense it's actually a car
but i don't i don't don't play the kara
khan like jeffrey sorry yeah we don't
have the standings or pairings quite yet
we're getting uh updated on this one as
we're getting ready for round number two
you could see a couple of moments as we
started all of it out and you can see
all of the grandmasters there at
queenside uh chatting it up between
their blitz rounds they're also just
waiting for the pairings how many 2600s
can you see in one still image
exactly exactly john burke from webster
we see all
right this is glitter in front of us
talking to catalina
we see var we see
is that mr bruzon that's the one aronian
on with this back to us
and he's speaking to roman caslov
got it and then you have your
posse over there in the corner yeah
the seleua
students the national champions over
there jj alimoran the action
extraordinary amount of talent the queen
side diner i want to say how about it i
mean generations of uh really top
players right there uh now the crucial
question that everybody wants to know is
how did varusian
they're
sneaking in the back door did uh var did
he
manage to at least win how are they
handling at the rc without far yeah i
don't know
we're told his game was was over very
quickly he was playing he was actually
playing as ree yang yan
oh oh
big clash though
nice but not the result we still uh
we're still waiting we're we're getting
uh waiting for all the results there we
see lavona raising aronian in his blue
shirt facing us
the gentleman on the left i've seen him
during when we were having these russian
broadcasts i just yeah he's actually a
grad student at webster okay
then we have uh in the men's how are we
there who just like
with the mohawk haircut after all what
where else do your uh arbiters in the
chess world have mo mo hair like it
seems like my student is trying to gain
some intel joining uh the slu student uh
group
and i'm curious about alice as well
how did how did our 12 year old finalist
i don't care what kind of blitz games
she got she was playing with
which is a very serious threat
huge opponent big big big rating and
there goes
round number two can we zoom on that
tony shouting everybody
take your seats i don't have the parks
yet
i remember i played a lot of blitz
tournaments where it was always take
your seats and else had a great
tournament in the american cup of course
second place for her yes she was
outclassed barana crush but who wasn't
in that tournament exactly really showed
tons of fighting spirit lots of
resourcefulness let's see what she can
bring to the blitz of course
oh she won me over i'm a true fan alice
lee has her own
show
alice's pawn palace how can you not like
a show with that title come on guys we
should all subscribe and uh support her
channel on it's chess kids doctor
excellent excellent
look it up we support her eight-time
national champion irena crush taking her
seat right now getting ready for her
match
and who
will join her at the table let's see
cause arena lost she started with a loss
against sanchez franklin exactly
it'd be nice to have parents
we are still waiting for pairings we see
peruvian grand masters jose martinez
alcantara
as well
a member of webster university
ooh am i saying alice versus yan
we're going to take a look at table
number one because i believe it's a
great match-up i think it's wesley saw
against benjamin gledura
oh my god number two is lavonda
i know that's crazy and who is fabi's
opponent by the way
i knew who that was i just forgot that
and oparin actually won in their last
clash at the grand prix in a classical
match
lev was supposed to win that game or
draw that game uh to advance to the
quarterfinals he did not manage to do
that and have give himself a chance to
qualify for the candidates wow in fact
but oparin stole that away from him and
i know leveronian wants revenge in this
one well just picking a random person
who happens to live in saint louis
to defeat one of the world's very very
best players in a you know
you know in a blitz tournament it's a
slow friday it's casual friday over here
at the club all right because we're
sporting our best american i'll read
i'll read that song swag wesley so
versus benjamin gledura very nice gregor
apartment against lemonade fabiano
dominguez being paired up as far
continue misha antifa against sam
shanklin
we have john michael burke against ilya
nizhnik
there's some good stuff over here
definitely as the player shake ends
round two of this scheduled nine round
blitz tournament underway and we see a
retie
g6 signaling that levon wants to play
bishop g7 e5 fast but c4 came on the
board
in their world championship match in
chennai
i like the way that
vichy handled the black pieces with this
early g6
against the reddy once again
93 knight xc4 recapturing the last pawn
now here because the pawn is on c5 i
tend to feel knight h6
and knight f5 is usually the way to go
you keep the bishop open
uh and as well as you eyeball the d4
pawn no the much more traditional knight
f6 was on
lavone's mind as he's played knight f6
knight d5
rather quickly
knight d5 closing that long diagonal the
bishop g2 is indeed going to become a
monster once that knight from f3 leaves
i saw it as a little bit of a defensive
move the move knight d5 in the sense
that maybe white wanted to play bishop
e3 and tickle the pawn on c5 knight d5
stops that
and now
that is exactly what the opponent is
going for a3 and b4 and b4
the most advanced pawn in black's camp
exactly now what levon is doing by
setting up his queen side in the style
he has he's looking to play bishop b7
and to try to neutralize
white's bishop on g2 a7 a5 stopping b4
once and for all and maybe threatening
possibly a threatening a5 a4
for long term
uh on the queen side
big moment right now for uh these
players because white has to choose a
plan at this moment queensland
eyeballing bishop h6
as well as bishop c3 to potentially
trade off this powerful dark square
bishop to be hey
i don't care
go ahead and
make your trade uh that was a surprise
move for me he executes the thread but
yeah
all right you're not gonna move it i'll
take it here we go oh f6 settings that's
some understanding
the understanding
bind uh set up coming here for
uh lavon and we do see the trade and the
problem bishops black and this is why i
think lebron played f6 is that after the
exchange of dark square bishop d4 is
coming very quickly and that's why we
see f6 e5 stopping for the moment at
least d4
yeah now the question is is white going
to be
persistent and play a line like e2 e3
to demonstrate his desire to to play d4
um
well it's a it's a moroxy bind but
nothing too special right it smells like
white white has a little bit of space
problems black has definitely the larger
amount of space but it's a position
you've traded off a couple of dark
square bishops exactly i like starting
to maneuver maybe something like 91 c2
push for the b4 break one day uh he
plays the move e3 trying to say i'm
gonna go d4 right away i've always liked
the hedgehog setups myself so e2e3 uh
definitely has my vote of confidence big
discrepancy on the clock between these
two players one minute and 32 seconds
for aparri in two minutes and 10 seconds
for aronia lavon has been playing rather
briskly i would say bishop e6 just
developing protecting the knight on d5
very good queen d7 coming up one thing
about d4 you have to be careful about e4
and that's why oparin plays queen to c2
to stop the move e4 right
also the knight on c4 although it looks
okay it actually doesn't do that much
it's controlled by the pawns yeah and it
could actually end up being a tactical
target now the question was uh d3 d4
immediately would have run into
something along the lines of bishop f5
so you get your rook off the diagonal
maybe the knight on c6 can become a
tactical target for white's pieces and
levonorhonian has played so far two
mizzou players
eliminated
i remember there's this great larry bird
basketball player story larry bird had
just made a a a shot and he went over to
the
opposing coach and he says don't you
have anybody on your lineup who can
guard me and the coach looked down
the row of players and said no
lavon's going to ask you the same
question coach don't you have anybody
that can stop me
that's rough i might have to suit up
nice and the knight on c4 which i
questioned did drop back to d2 uh
spinning around the board as it found
the square e4 it's very usual useful i
find in some positions to play h2h4 what
are we doing a4 g3 g4 guys
no g
and that's
g5 now take advantage of the absence of
the dark score of bishop is that a plan
no uh
it's it's a very risky that's an
aggressive very aggressive plan i'm not
sure
but i do like h4
uh it's it's often times that the move
h5 can uh weaken the square f5
and we've
seen 28 kg move you never know 94 i am
like wait wait
that's so all right that's a great move
okay
that's what's up
that's one of the longest moves i've
ever seen
i think he is setting up for g4 g5 i
think you're right i think you're right
g5 what about g5 immediately do you
actually sacrifice no you don't right
not in this instance
he probably goes sliding all the way
back i don't know
well the players are and knight takes c3
and dividing b takes e3 yeah which
usually gives more central control but
hey where did we see this before the
from yesterday
how they learn from their games right
this was such a good defensive mechanism
for him last year against favi that
bishop on b3 was defending f7 here
here's the moment
are we going to see g3 g4 g4 or do you
see d4 here c4
cutting the bishop none of the
above it cuts the bishop from the rest
of the game that does not drawbacks how
do you deal with the pressure on the
default knight 91
bishop to d5 knight g2 e493 let's go
he's listening to you
and he has to play fast there's a very
big time difference once again 15
seconds oh g4 finally on the board makes
more sure
15 against 30 all right beautiful
camera work there on the action and by
the way that move knight
e7 did stop bishop to d5 five night
which was one of those automatic moves
ooh he stopped at e4 a little surprise
knight is going to come back
now we see b5 trying to open things up
on the queen side doesn't that just make
weaknesses the pawn on c5 sure looks
like an opportunity and i think lavon is
being outplayed here i think it's
totally coming right right i agree with
you i i like white's position much more
more places
you're taking a defensive stance
wow
opening up the h file with the capturing
and king g2 sure has my uh
yeah there you go boy these moves are
too easy
eight seconds for obama 16 15 seconds
for leveroni oh my gosh it's it's fast
and furious here it comes
bishop e4 is the rook going to slide
over oh that's a big threat right now
bishop takes c4 i was expecting the rook
to slide over to c2 myself yeah i
thought the extra extra repair
we're important for
attacking purposes and but i don't like
this c-pawn guys i don't like it oh i
think they i think the advantage is just
what a cool move i mean just stepping
back just stepping back queen queen
what's the follow-up right now after c2
c2 rook to c1 knight
to follow now the queen is getting ready
to go
queen c6 what a move
no
queen could have gone to c3 no but this
is also good it's over it's over that's
right he's so far away from the action
okay that's pretty good but rookie seven
was for science
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
no i think he gets it i think he gets
two
two minutes and uh said enough i think
he resigned anyway
these days now get punished with a
penalty absolutely they do not lose
let's see if we have any games
wow what an under promotion on people
versus shankland still going on right
now it's the only game i think it's four
five i think it's board five table
number five excuse me you're right it's
table number five and they're only with
the only ones playing at the moment as
sam shanklin from the american cup he
didn't see them right there there you go
and they've got a crowd including our
our broadcaster verusion
wesley sowe in his blue blazer jacket
leads with 2-0 he's one of the perfect
scorers and we have a bishop end game
with an extra pawn for sam shanklin and
one is on h5 and the power of h6 we can
just show the 2d board for a second
right so we can see what's going on
exactly we should pick those yeah
and it does appear as if sam
had
with the extra pawn there's a bishop of
seven you're going to
be winning this game actually he's just
gone
this is a draw you should play
yeah you just switch the diagonal right
the moment you threaten to switch
diagonals yourself you go the other way
go the other way nice
now i'm threatening to switch diagonals
again with bishops to c4 and now he
wants to go bishop
and you switch diagonals bishop a4 if
you go bishop e2 go bishop eight you go
bishop f7 or go bishop d1 that's a
beautiful ending it's all about this
pawn on h5 and how we're gonna attack it
as soon as the bishop comes here the
white bishop goes to the other side to
the other flank to defend it and
it's a positional draw i don't think
this goes anywhere yeah very nice
positional trial at some point black
will have to go for g4 and try to have
enough time to go king g5 but that's not
going to be the case nope
you came to f6 once again threatening
bishop to f7 bishop has to move away
from the diagonal exactly
and again this is the three plus two
time control so the players are getting
a bonus of two seconds for every time
they complete their move
move is considered completed when you
made the move
left the piece on the board and press
the clock
and
i i think that
bishop takes h5
and the draw
is about to be agreed and that was the
case what a marathon fight there we do
have some
revolutions
clipped uh lanier the higher
rated linear dominguez for a draw so two
players giving him trust yeah two
players giving up draws and elie and
nishnik on board six actually losing uh
john michael burke uh
just wow
junior uh player defeats one of the
highest rate players in the united
states yeah it just shows you how much
talent there is in nishnik's actually
the board six of the
of the event right
right
that's crazy
very nice take a look at
the
end of the lavon game in slow motion you
guys can take that one let me go through
the standings real quick back over to
you christian well actually this is the
game between oparin and aronian queen
takes a3 not the best rook d7 i think
would have won the game on the spot but
yes and now
white is threatening queen h7 if you
make a queen queen h7 might disturb you
but i just i simply don't think he was
looking at the board he thought that he
for sure will get a queen on screen yeah
and calculating what happens after queen
to age seven or queen to h6 forgetting
the fact that that's the knight
[Laughter]
oh
and
levon stops the clock to to say no no no
you haven't lost the game by leaving
your kingdom pre you did make an illegal
move you don't lose the game but no no i
said no no no i don't want to see the
rest rook is coming to see two and it's
uh curtains if you will it would have
been a checkmate in that one as the end
after knight takes c1 for example just
to give you an idea if you do take on c1
i'm not actually going to take back on
c1 i'm going to throw in the check the
queen is controlling the third rank the
king cannot run upwards has to go
backwards and queen to c1 just finishes
precisely with a checkmate and in fact i
was looking through the game it seemed
like at this point still
white is a better after bishop to d5 but
after this knight to f3 queen to ea the
computer is saying double question mark
and h4 came on the board h6
h takes g5 this whole plan very tempting
plan of getting the rook on the h-file
trying to double up and trying to
checkmate the king the problem is that i
have a lot of defenders around my king
not only the queen and the knight but
also we've seen how important the rook
on the seventh rank was defending this
crucial h7 square he did not understand
that why that is the computer is saying
h5 i'm actually interested in gaining
more space on this side h5 and after
that knight to e1 open up the position
potentially with
f4 and try to take an advantage like
that he did not do that and after rook
to h1 just focusing too many of his
resources on the h while on the king
side and allowing the c pawn to go down
the board which well it spelled a lot of
trouble for white who succumbed under
the pressure by the way just that moment
where you do play the move h5
if you don't mind it looks like lavone
would have been in trouble in that
particular case yes because after h5 you
follow it up with the move d4 you don't
play
yeah you you the knight goes back and
then there's a there's a double pin
there's a pin against the e pawn because
the queen on g3 i love it it's a rook
and there's a pin on the c file so
uh uh
because of queen takes c7 this might
have been what he missed because yeah if
you do allow the knight to get back to
d6 after midway knight to d6 then black
is most likely going to be just fine
exactly but he doesn't have time d4
comes i'm targeting your pawn structure
trying to get to your king and the only
thing you can do as black in this
position is to actually play defensive
right with knight to f7 which of course
allows bishop to g6 visually bishop g6
is such a beautiful move targeting one
of your defenders uh it does seem that
this position is going in white's favor
absolutely just going also over the game
between verusion
and
lanier we saw a lot of maneuvering going
on there but in truth the players never
really
uh clashed they never went through no it
was like it was a very very soft uh game
with just a lot of gnashing of teeth and
no real we only have
six players on a perfect two out of two
right and that's it we got wesley saw
fabiana caron and john michael burke
lavonna rony and ray robson and
anna satonski oh
she beat
savion
to start the tournament
yeah no kidding right
that's the way to start the tournament
go anna zatanski and then the other one
she be in your second round
she is so far down it's got a hard
trouble finding
number nine
jose jose martinez alcantara really a
strong 2600 grand master yeah there you
go ana satoshi and two out of two
blistering start to the tournament anna
and red say yeah
boys are easy
bang bang next
whoa
yeah that's the current standings let me
just switch this around very very very
nice everybody i see uh
talia stelia cervantes also of the us
women's champion
which school is she's from mine oh
very nice in fact two uh slough students
who we see so lucky though who played in
the american cup as well chatting it up
with her best friend begin to genova
and harshit raja for both students at
mizzou and now we have round number
three posted by international arbiter my
camera yeah and i have the pairings for
you at least the relevant
we're going to start off with ray robson
against wesley saw of course great
that's going to be number one
uh but we also have levon against john
michael burke also very interesting game
that would be on table number two but i
gotta go with ana's a ton of board
number three
anna cetonski fabiano caruana both
players and a perfect score yes ana yeah
let's go we're going to give up
[Music]
in the sun let's make it happen and hey
wait a minute look at that pregame
talking to one another what was that
what was that
anna and red there she's where's table
three where's table three the sermon is
so ridiculous he's strong i know becky
has a bite
the game has a what
what's that terrible i thought there
were 34 players
we lost
a player a player got stuck in traffic i
mean they just lied to us as usual oh
they got stuck in traffic something
happened we lost a player as ana's
atomski's taking the white pieces
against our american cup champion
uh fabiano let's go hannah i know that
everybody's ruining the one of the one i
love the double elimination right yeah
except for one small detail that can't
be overlooked players like anna who are
slow starters normally
they warm up you know give them a couple
of rounds and then they start really
feeling uh their strength uh she never
got no she never got past the gate yeah
she won her first game against abraham
yeah three glasses in a row to tatev and
then just couldn't pick herself back up
against salakiru exactly keep a very
close eye on the game between ray robson
and wesley so and keep you guys in touch
with that one as well by the way
the first one between ray robson and
wesley that's on board one as wesley so
once again the highest rate player in
the field he's up against a an olympic
teammate and uh that is a kind of a game
that could decide a u.s championship uh
playing on board
on round three and a blizzard i love it
queen's gambit declined and look at on a
go oh she knows her position as well it
doesn't matter who's sitting in front of
her
moran variation yeah she's a very it's
just traditionalist you know if you have
to describe how anna plays chess very
classical very very classical agreed and
we've seen if i'm not mistaken this idea
with b3 in that game between
sam savion and who was it against
against ray ross
right yeah yeah
it was this kg line where ray
found a miracle check on f5 that kept
him alive exactly yeah by the way uh i
think for students of the game uh just
watch the way
anna moves her pieces she uses the same
hand for all of her piece
movement right hand
hits the clock with the right hand
and
not using two hand single hand use and
very smooth
easy quick play by anna she's about to
play queen b1 getting her queen
off the c file but right now this move
c5 came is a little bit unpleasant the
knight on f3 lacks a little protection
and usually after c5 the response is c
takes d5 exactly and taking advantage of
the fact that you cannot recapture
backbone on anything
on h7 is being hit by both the screen
and d3 yeah this looks like a
particularly good time right to play
c4 takes d5 if we see e6 takes d5 the
bishop often lands on the f5 square yes
yeah this feels like i'm actually got
the little bit better yes without
playing our american cup champion thus
far
and clock times uh
well two minutes and 15 seconds against
two minutes and 40 seconds for fabiano
carolina and we do see that bishop land
on f5 you were mentioning i like white's
position a little bit more
i do too uh look at it on a go i i
cannot fault anything in her play thus
far
nobody believes you this is
e4 is just killing blood that's so ugly
i know i know i didn't do it i'm just
saying that you take on c4 you do not
want to play d5 take c i think fabi is
taking enormous strategic risks oh hey
oh yeah but
he's practical right he does have the
time advantage and it's growing and
growing and growing it's almost up to a
minute in a three-minute game anna has
always had issues with that in classical
and in blitz clearly it's also an issue
uh something to be said for knight b5
bishop b8
knight e5 there is a pin
there is a pin on the d7 night that
might prove awkward for fabby she's
going for it going for it i'll speak a
little slow softly
and she's going for that precise
tactical sequence
it doesn't feel like that's right
i know eight
and bc was
was obviously the strongest but knight
b5 because now a6 is a problem a6
followed by b5 if i managed to
strengthen that pawn complex d5 and c4
then black is going to have the
initiative on the queen side you have to
get ready for that you can play a4 to
stop that or you can go for this knight
t5
switching gears and targeting that d6
square actually
very much so why not
you could win potentially the two
bishops you never take on d7 you'd be
base three to h3 in a nanosecond do not
think over this force moves anna and
she's played it a little bit too slow
for my taste but look at this move
knight e4 the difference in strength is
simply how fast they make the moves
there's nothing else really to it anna's
playing a great game
wow even throwing in the move knight e5
perhaps it looks like a sacrifice but i
don't think you can open up so many
diagonals and lines against your own
king with bishop takes e5 and that's why
we see the move f5
i'm still worried about the time
but 40 seconds for anna two minutes and
eight seconds for fabiano he's huge
knight g5 traps the bishop on h3 that's
the problem yeah that's a problem oh oh
i think this position is unraveling for
white
five let's go let's do it let's do it
come on come on
you're already lost right you have to go
for it
30 seconds maybe less too much time over
the sacrifice she's going to have no
no time
difference come on anna
oh
see she doesn't like to part with the
pieces but those double h pawns they're
going to be here before yeah we're still
in a game right yes we're still playing
we're still fighting okay d6
and look fc the other knight all right
queen g2 h4 let's go knight he's jumping
towards e4 now knight c3 was stranded
the knight on b5 was stranded guys i
think this was actually a very decent
move actually yeah yeah to bring the
knight back into play
cover the e4 square for what it's worth
and just hope your king side
your shattered king side uh won't cost
you the game she's failing it guys now
she has to stop black's initiative on
the queen side a6 b5 followed by a5 if
you allow me to end b4 is going to come
on the board you have to find your own
counter chances on the king side but
despite the fact that you gave that
light square bishop on h3 that opens up
the possibility of this h4 h5 and
opening you up on the king side i'm
starting to warm up to white's position
how about you guys yeah i'm feeling
better i don't like the smoke rook c1 i
would oh i'm right i'm happy to get rid
of this dark square bishop in truth
because that dark square bishop was not
doing white any good
queen comes over to g2 i really wanted
to play six how do i learn to play queen
b2 b4
queen b by the way you have to be very
careful at a rook exchange sacrifices on
the c file if you go queen to g5 yes
knight is coming to g3 potentially
hitting f5 but more importantly making
h3h4h h5 to break up the king side team
that
fabi has carefully constructed for
himself again knight g3 will come with
the dual purpose threat
h4h5 as well as knight takes f5 anna
anna's putting some pressure i'll tell
you
the fact that it's eight seconds i guess
40 but ooh family
heavy feelings of the heat here knight
g3 is going to knight g3
bishop takes e2 i like this move 30
seconds for fabiano knight takes f5
check
is the only one c1 rook c1 is playable
right yes oh poor anna had to recapture
that rook she was just dreaming about
knight takes f5 but b2
10 seconds to 20 seconds
anna zatonski giving fabiano all
he can handle h4 let's go yes yes let's
go all right anna is playing for you
anna is playing the beast
wonderfully well
i like it
three is hanging out of one oh not from
bishop a6 e3 is hanging guys
which one what whoa what he didn't play
why didn't he play queen takes e3 that
is a very good question i don't know but
now g6 is hanging probably queen to c2
he was afraid of allowing the queen to
um
play
play
nasty
this i control everything this movie
midnight takes h5 and queen g7
oh night h5 minute that's a real serious
threat uh look at this
five seconds for four
oh
stop being queen g7 mate no
b4 and unfortunately a5 and that's a
passer for black yeah i don't think that
she's catching
[Music]
it was so close i think she shouldn't
have taken on h5 she would have taken
the knight on e4 queen g5 exactly oh and
i was also thinking about the knight
sacrifice when she played f6 knight
takes h5 and queen g5 as well
that looked like oh on a really
a very very sportive good play by anna
she had knocked over the piece she put
it properly on the square before
pressing the clock very very good
sportsmanship there by anna i think
she's having respect
where she's trying to she still has
these pawn guys f6 she still has the
eighth h pawn can go not after king six
oh king six ninety
oh she could have played knight takes d5
which seven is this okay
i don't know
uh that knight
he's dropping back
no d3 he goes oh
unfortunately
the black king is pressing now
oh that's a beautiful move
well done by fabi there and now you can
i don't think oh
he had to pull all his tricks from that
back in order to survive what a map wow
what a match by anna wow she must have
been good at some point oh really really
really good she played
she played a great game i mean fabby had
to play
a great game as well
let's take a look first of the results
of some of the other games ray robson
did draw that game against wesley so on
board number two arunian beat uh john
michael burke so that will give him
lavona roni yeah three points a perfect
uh and fabian the only perfect scorer so
they'll be meaning but sam shanklin
defeated jeffrey zhang but sam had given
up a draw as we previously saw against
antipov that's right
so there's a bunch of people in two and
a half actually not that many but one of
them is the grand master version okovian
who's defeated with the black pieces
ilya nizhnik he's on two and a half out
of three govar but only not bad at all
only three peop only two people with
three out of three fabira caruana and
levon
and as we prepare for a break we just
want to
show you some swag that you can get from
cute boutique alejandro uh let's see
what we got today we have um
thank you for watching the 2022 american
cup
please enjoy 20 of all regular prize
merchandise today with the code am cup
20 at checkout offer valid only at
kiboutikl.com
and on the right side you can see the
little pin that's on the set like on the
vest
it's not some alien hardware no it's a
pin it's a blown up uh image it's a
blown up image of a painting and then
you've got a bag what's the bag for is
that like a camera bag or something
that's in front of the vest it's a
computer bag oh sorry a computer bag
yeah it's all twenty percent off at
boutiquestl.com use our promo code and
thank you for watching our broadcast
that's the way to support it we're gonna
take a call uh short break there's a
10-minute break at the tournament we're
going to take a 10-minute break here and
we'll be back with round number four of
this exciting event
[Music]
it's time for the return of the grand
chess tour featuring the world's best
players in some of the most unique
places across the globe romania poland
croatia and the united states join us in
may as we kick off the 2022 tour in
romania and then immediately followed by
poland this is your chance to see the
best players in the world's greatest
game follow all of the action live at
granchester.org
chess the smartest game on earth
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene there's more
here than meets the eye from lao meyer
sculpture park and the city garden to
the stunning cathedral basilica one of
the largest mosaic collections in the
entire world
so if art is your thing
st louis is on display all year long
ooh
now that's an exhibit
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody let's jump
straight into the action we are in the
blitz of the american cup 2022 a nine
round tournament and we have this
rematch of the american cup finals are
the only two players currently at three
out of three fabiano carrano with the
white pieces against levon aronian let's
take a look at the position right away
we started with some kind of kohli
system knight f3 d4 knight and came d5
c4 knight c6 and a6 and the players are
moving very quickly you can't beat
perfection three out of three but boy
did fabby need all of his bag of tricks
to get past anna's zatanski
and anna was putting up a wonderful
struggle and we have a rematch as you
mentioned of the finals of the american
cup can lavone get a measure of revenge
yeah we'll find out but here i believe
that he is
under a tiny bit of pressure but
well you have the hanging pawns and the
bishop on h5
is actually
released it's not behind
the structure the bishop is not
wallowing on the d7 square for example
so i kind of like
the full throttle battle we
that black has managed to achieve not so
easy against fabi fabby when he's white
it's usually a difficult person to get
good play against queen b6 tickling the
bishop on b2 which is now
blocked
that attack is blocked and the queen
trade normally with hanging
hanging
hanging pawns the queen trade usually
favors the player who's facing
the hanging pawns
now yeah you have these weaknesses as
permanent then we've talked about the
necessity for initiative and at both
iqp's and hanging pawns throughout the
tournament and i think that this is not
an exception not at all rook d8 rook d1
i rather okay knight d7 is certainly one
approach another approach that i rather
like there as well by black was bishop
to g6
and knight e4 uh knight d7 invites d5
and well
uh fabi didn't have to be asked twice i
love this move though this backwards
with knight a7
and he zipped it too
nice move 995.
takes advantage of the fact that black's
just a bit passive in this position the
pawn on b7 is targeted yes
it's just a tempe it's the couple of
tempeh here and there where white can
find this initiative okay knight c5 i
think is more or less
forced to stop yeah the issues that
black is having you don't want to play b
b6 b7 b7 b6 and allow knight b7 a6 would
be hanging in that case knight c5 though
might just be temporary bishop d the
bishop d4 with d5
so we don't have an immediate way of
exploiting
the situation
one thing you can do is maybe perhaps
start with g4 and try to get the other
knight to the center knight to e5
looks very attractive i'm attracted to
just going bishop e5 and playing for d6
but
well actually yeah right now
well
is kind of defended so bishop e5 also
like e5 might be a problem right
but an ib5 you can take maybe bishop
takes b5 and then follow it up with d6
again three plus two you don't want to
go into a one-minute tank you mourn
against that at the opening of the show
alejandro that is not the way you do it
those one those one-minute things
usually don't pay off
in these blitz games where you use 30 of
your time the worst part about a
one-minute think is when you make it and
your opponent replies instantly and you
have to go into a tank again exactly
it's like you didn't see the response or
you were slow to it knight b5 the knight
on a7 was doing nothing knight on b5 can
now retreat to d6 a very nice blockade
which will defend guard the pawn on b7
as well as with the knight on b5 bishop
d4 is no longer an option try to put
more pressure on that knight on c5 if
you cannot attack my knight on c5 then
how are you going to untangle this
position as white because if you go
knight a to c4 that allows knight to b3
every single night jump for white gives
up one important square what is this
time difference 30 seconds
more than serious suddenly much more
than serious
change sacrifice desperation
so we go rook takes c5 knight takes bc
with the bishop and we move away the
rook from d8 right
correct
i think that's the easiest that's the
easiest i don't know it's in exchange
for a pawn though not only that but also
after knight and he's got the c6 square
but how it might not have been the worst
exchange sacrifice i've ever seen
there's some problems with the pin
though this is what i'm worried about
for example if i go knight d6
knight takes bishop takes on d6 the
knight on e5 would like to go to c6 but
remember that e2 is hanging so right so
d6 knight takes c5
or even bishop takes a6
getting out of that chain
and getting the next round
by the way a4 on the board telling that
knight if you go back to d6 i'm going to
play bishop takes a6
um i
an h4 no
hold on what am i looking at on my board
it has h4 and on the live board it has
a4 i think it's fine that's funny
bishop takes a6 looks like a good move
he gets back that pawn
right for choice coming almost out of
nowhere right you have right two pawns
the two bishops open position oh the
move rook a5 snags the a4 pawn though
does it though yeah there's the magnum
on d6 is always covering the b5 square
what was why didn't
why didn't
white get in the bishop a3 i like this
move bishop to b5 tempting the knight
take on b5 but that would allow the
d-pawn to round down the board
i like what fabiano is doing he's
getting some chances
is it true
f6
f7
yeah you take i think you take that's a
big move f6 is a big move he found it
and rotates b5 now what about d6 oh
exactly takes b to just d let's make a
draw and let's make a draw let's make a
draw i'm happy with why to make a
drawing this because i think you're
happy with black to make a draw too no
everybody's happy bishop he says no d7
looks like a draw bishop takes c6 and
it's bishops of opposite colors that's a
lot of things by the way once again
played with one second guys the clock
times it's six seconds for five forty
seconds for a level one
but this is very safe right no it is
safe but again it's about the clock and
that
that two second increment yeah has
really built up the time and wow draw
there between the winners jumping to the
game between var
and ray
kobien who's been at the truck learning
chassis
here on the left against ray robson made
it all the way to the fourth place this
bar is a pawn to the good var is
pressing and ahead on the clock 17
seconds against four seconds
let's go yeah check on b6 followed by a6
no he decides to soften up
oh look at this technique and king g
three to f4 and tickets going for it
guys
you go back to the b5 square there's no
threads for black so yeah rook to a2 has
to keep contact with the pawn on f2 rook
to b5
now what about taking the rook on the a
file i think this is the time to put the
rook on the a5 then get the pawn to a7
whoa he has not done it and then invade
with the king
that seems like oh he's gone the other
way he's i'm i i'm not a fan of this
straight
wasn't this the exact end game that
begum had with solakidu with um
we thought it yeah it was a thought of
but
here he is the only difference is
because the rook is not
in front of the pawn he's going for the
a pawn he's going to win the rook you
know that once again
you're going to lose that route and king
b6 with the threat of rook a5 oh okay
five right wait no okay not immediately
after a7 why why wasn't rook a5 just
winning i think this is winning i think
this might be what's going on because i
think it's good enough yeah e4 because
he's already cut off he's already cut
off e4 would be i think it would have
been easier to just play king c6 let's
go var
showing the slew assistant coach check
he's still there i think he's still
there i think
easy win easy win no problem you get to
play e4
what a strong and we still have should
we have the game between wesley and sam
which is on march
so let's move right to that one yeah and
two olympic teammates
playing against one another as tony rich
blocking our camera
thank you tony and what we have we have
two pawns two past pawns on b and c rook
and knight who's playing for a win uh
the pawns i would assume well definitely
the pawns now
uh but is it a draw i think so i think
so right
just an easy draw on knight to e6
yeah that's nothing to do here in 1966
wow hence what we
uh just the end of that as again wesley
so our number one seed
has been clipped for two draws he has
what are some of the top standings we
also see that lanier dominguez has
beaten john michael burke on board four
on board five seven seven three and a
half out of four like the rest of the
tournament leaders right sam savion
started with a loss against anastatonsky
and since has won three games in a row
just beating benjamin gledura and on six
board another man on the way to recovery
jose montines alcantara alcantara sorry
has played against robbie kepler and won
when we started the broadcast for round
four you said this
tournament is ridiculous
as one of the top players with the 2600
rating came in is sporting an 0 and 3
result who was that man that was yuniski
quesada he actually started off by
losing to my student
gabriela i i don't know how you lose to
on top and then you get paired against
jeffrey chung but then you get paired
against jeffrey
lost that one they got paired against
lost that one and then got a bite
wow
thank goodness for the bike christian
jump right in what it's called your eye
my friend well i was looking through
this game that we just saw the end of
the one between wesley and sam shanklin
and actually wesley was completely
winning he had this end game with two
extra pawns and right now came the big
blunder bishop to h3 it's an easy win
for white you cannot take on e4 because
rook two f4 is going to come with a
discovery checks and i'm going to pick
up the recon e4 instead of that then i'm
not 100 sure what he missed he played
this move bishop to c4
giving a check and just allowing knight
takes c4 giving a piece in one move
because you cannot take on c4 rook takes
e4 actually would win game for black the
rook on f5 is
not protected anymore by the pawn on e4
and after king takes f5 this is just
game over so bishop to c4 a double quest
triple quadruple question mark move
knight takes c4 and that allowed sam
back into the game huge miss by wesley
sowing this one guys that's absolutely
bishop h6 h3 would have been egregious
or g2 and
anywhere probably bishop to a6 as well
right this should be winning okay you're
going to take an another pawn and it's
going to be a two versus one but i have
the bishop i have the rook that's a nice
coordination the knight on e5 not as
strong tied to the defense of the pawn
on c6 this would be an easy conversion
for wesley
he did
he played bishop c4 what a big miss for
him i thought the game
that we
focused upon the fabi versus levon
aronian game was a game that had a lot
of content in it just for a blitz game
that was really really fun let's see the
end of this game in slow motion because
it came down to one second yeah and i
think this is right now
look look look
as he's trying to promote the pawn to
put the queen on the board eating his
bigger head
barely made that it was down to one
second less than a second there pretty
sure who loves living life on the edge
as we saw in this match with jeffrey
zhang from the american cubs that was
pretty funny that was very good and then
these quick moves he quit he built up
his time and then a draw was shortly
agreed once
eleven seconds appeared on uh seven on
fabulous
clock
he was a happy one yeah once again
finally out of the run
once you get that increment you're on
safe grounds but wow one second and he
had to find some resources just to keep
alive in that position yes he did yes he
did lavone had some great pressure so as
we get
prepped for our round five match-ups
just tell us once again our tournament
standings and who's doing what to whom
uh i don't know how many times but i won
five players i think i'm going to guess
i think i'm pretty good at this fabiano
carana and lemonado definitely have
three and a half points correct they are
joined i believe only by lanier i know
by order janakobian
at two and a half and on three points we
have
uh sam shanklin wesley so
uh linear dominguez
jose martinez alcantara i don't know how
the antipov versus burke game finn sorry
antipa versus
a satonski game finish that's a big one
yes the winner of antifa versus he also
has three points as we see this bunch of
grandmasters at queenside getting ready
or chatting it up really
between rounds uh all of their friends
on the board on off the board as you can
see
well i mean that uh two years of
pandemic lockdown it's just nice to see
people socializing uh this is like one
of the largest groups of people i've
seen in the chess world and sometimes i
have the standings around in carana
cobian all of them with three these are
the three players tied for first with
three points we have jacqueline
dominguez and tipoff saw sevilla and
martinez alcantara all at the score of
three and one yeah and two and a half we
have robson apparent and jeffrey shong
and irina crush very nice yes
and we have the pairings up let me just
read them to you guys
the current pairings we have leonardo
against varujan akovi and i think it's
going to be number one unless we want to
go to wesley saw against fabiano caruana
two great pairings
i think we have to give uh varus in our
experience i think we're going with
varuge number one we're going to table
number one with levon ironian against
varujin akovi because he's been in the
truck stuck there for like 10 days i
know we're gonna give him some spotlight
we're giving it a little love i mean uh
poor guy he's been working so hard this
last two weeks
not enough chest
you have not enough chest after today
we may have but we've got the grand
chest tour on tap and it comes up in
just a few days may 3rd is the opening
ceremony of the superbad chess classic
over there in bucharest romania we will
be losing christian as he boards a
flight to go to bucca wrestlemania and
interview the players after their games
absolutely the first round will be on
may 5th and immediately after the
superman chess classic in bucharest will
be moving on to the super bad rapping
and blitz but in warsaw poland only a
couple of days after that classic in
romania and remember that the mag the
world champion magnus carlsen will be
joining us for the zagreb gct in late
july just before the olympia we will
have a pause uh for the month of june as
we allow the gran the candidates the
world championship candidates tournament
to determine a challenger to the world
champion will be played in june and then
just as you were saying come july the
grand chess tour picks up again this
time in zagreb that's right all right
then finishing our tour this year we'll
be here in st louis for the rapid and
blitz and of course the sinkfield cup
again yesterday huge announcement that
the grand chess tour will in the near
future
pick two candidates for
uh the candidates tournament as they're
underway uh two very good friends by the
way uh lavonne and var sitting down
there at the table the london system but
this time it's met by an early uh
normally in these positions the threat
of knight h4 precipitates h2h3 as played
and both players playing very quickly
two minutes 59 seconds three
minutes for var staying ahead on the
clock yes virus is a seasoned
professional of blitz
he's been around he's got a high blitz
rating he's actually played even magnus
carlsen at the world championship of
blitz exactly
in this particular system yeah
castle knight to d7
now white is trying to set up some sort
of pressure on the e file potentially
setting up this idea of d5 later on in
the game
closing the bishop on b7 no a7 a6 with
the idea of gaining a little space on
the queen side b5
knight b6 is what var intended that was
immediately
met by a2 a4 shutting down that type of
play
but at this moment the players are just
completing their development we're going
to see
where the players are going to
concentrate their forces let's move
knight c4 tapping the d6 pawn is a kind
of indication that levon wants to play
through the center as well as on the
queens this move knight to c4 though
allows also black to go b5 at certain
moments so white really needs to keep an
eye on that idea of b5 a b a b and
knight a3 again it's this pawn on d6
usually you put the bishop on f
8 in such positions as shows a little
bit more flexibility
sometimes you play for the move e6 e5
bishop c6
perhaps setting up a battery on the long
diagonal with queen to b7 later on
nevertheless the queen right now on c7
nicely defends and barks playing the
most varge as possible
not a single
yeah we used to tease uh olf anderson a
great grandmaster from sweden that he
liked these hedgehogs set up so much
that he never crossed the fourth uh the
move b5 very aggressive very aggressive
yes
unstylistic
and now night
changing training of the rooks and var
says okay
i will uh
i'll take the a file i wonder what tom's
doing in the truck he's probably very
confused about what game this is yeah
yeah guys guys guys
knight to f5 is an option right now
isn't it
goes for it
the bishop belongs on f8
he forgot about this tactical mirage
knight to f5
if you take on f5 rook take c7 comes and
that position is just shattered
no no the position already falls apart
the problem of course is this bishop on
h2 is lurking hits the pawn on d6 as
does the knight on f5 double attack to
the bishop on e7 upon a d6
a clear oversight just a stone cold
oversight
var forgot about knight f5 the bishop
should have been
defensively minded on f8 this is a very
unpleasant decision for var but he's
trying to make a virtue out of necessity
as he's taken and
you got to take with a bishop otherwise
bishop takes d6 would cost you the game
at the very least he does not actually
is lost upon yet yet yet so he can be
happy about that
uh that's
about you can't be happy about that but
the only question is can we questions
trap no queen queen e1 now f3 you have
to be very careful about because f3 rook
to e8 you might get checkmated
f3 queen can come to g3 hit the pawn on
d6 uh so how do you defend the pawn on
d6 right now exactly i was thinking
quick c6 f3 is the issue driving the
bishop back and then maybe queen g3
hitting the d6 pawn i don't see how that
guy survives
var has got to put his trust in
counter play based on rook a1
hope
that the rook on we're following that
variation
rook to e8 move but it seems
like uh aronian just simply calculated
everything on vars time while var was
trying to figure out what to do aronian
just simply calculated everything and
right now he has everything set up for
rook takes eight queen takes c8 king to
h7 and then the follow-up really
potentially is bishop to d3
even queen e7 just attacked that pawn on
d6 again i love it i love it i was
trying to weaken the darkness i like
bishop d3 first exactly i'm a little
concerned about bishop e6 but once again
queen to e7 okay and then d5 setting up
some sort of uh yeah blockade like that
yes but uh
just go for the part and yeah
at this point i'm playing bishop c4 i'm
hoping
oops i was i was about to say i'm
playing bishop c4 i'm hoping
uh to get uh a light square blockade
oops
yeah ponte the good and the two bishops
well how do we feel about takes takes
knight c4
i have a couple of options uh first of
all white right even after you take on
b2 even after you take on beat white
take on b5 oh that's right yeah so i can
go bishop before i can go bishop a3 c7
pretty much anything that's great right
and also i think b3 might be a problem
next and by the way
that precise variation with bishop takes
b5 on
avar is hoping that with his knight on
c4 he can construct some kind of a
fortress but
nope
magnus carlson will say you don't get
your fortress just be careful
i don't believe you don't go king f2
because that would allow
a scorpion's thing knight to d1
nice
nice
okay so you have to be you have to nurse
the extra pawn slowly slowly king
f1 and king e2
what do you think about that just bring
the king over into play i like maybe
king g6 king h5 king f4 var could kick
up a fuss
that's too far you're too far away from
that
i think that's a good thing for the
bishop on that fade right
f4
f4 i was indeed worried about that plan
of yours yes sir wow
trying to stop him all together uh that
is just a little too preemptive like
sometimes you you you can be too careful
but g4 h4 h5 wait what is var doing
right now well he's saying you have a
bad dark square bishop it's not that bad
it's not that bad is it and by the way
for the moment it's keeping black's king
out bishop to e7 right very technical
so that he's so why is he not playing
the move king to f1 followed by king to
e2 it's just the patient man that's all
there is to it i don't know
now you have to stop bishop h5
what
you give up that beautiful h-bond
another pawn i think everything is
losing it doesn't matter
why not let's pick it up
i'm thinking if nothing else i can okay
big
knight to d2 and knight e4
is on var's agenda one second for var
whoa
one second play the move with one second
now oh my goodness two
one he's gonna flag flag and that's a
flag let's jump straight into the wesley
game that is board number two between
wesley saw and fabiano caruana because
we have a crazy material imbalance poppy
with the queen against three minor
pieces but
there's an e2 pawn board number two fab
looks winning wesley so that's just the
check mate come on check me
well
hopefully
fabi
is about to deliver a checkmate on
wesley so
uh nevermind never mind bishop c5 was
not it wasn't the checkmate bad
transmission error yeah we have a
decision so it's two bishops
against the queen and
uh oh we're gonna look no no you're not
gonna lose one of those bishops no he
doesn't lose a bishop and he puts a
bishop on g3 what this might be uh
fortress
2 bishop h3
i would i would rather have put the
bishop on f3 and the king on g2 myself
while he's listening to you he's
listening to you
how do i i don't think so i think this
is a very easy draw as we're getting the
backside of some very interested
spectator hg
uh it looked like dennis burroughs by
the way
and h5h4 but is this sufficient h5 is
coming okay the bishop should drop back
already
what a move giving up the long diagonal
setting out the control via h3 c8 h3
diagonal i think he wants to get in
bishop g4 f3 if you can
oh he would love to do that but i don't
know if you have time
h3 is coming he's gonna go to f1 but
that's not going to help him he's not
that might be a better better uh
oh
oh h3
how does it win a mission it's making
g4 that's crazy
[Music]
breaks through the bishops oh my
goodness and we don't actually have that
game they never updated that
game means that levon and fabi are
sharing first is that right that is
correct one of five you're sharing first
a horrific blunder
in in sam shanklin versus martinez
alcantara we can probably take a look at
that one which board is that that is
board number
four okay
and i will uh i will show it to you over
here just a second yes sir so it seems
like this position white is still
winning right let's see what happens
queen to f2 this seems to be losing some
of its advantage knight takes h5 would
potentially be on tap but now after
knight h5 d takes e6 allowing knight to
f4
this was played knight f4
rock queen to f2 and now black is the
one who has the advantage
let's see if he followed it up nope
return the favor with f takes e6 rook
takes d1 was more precise rook takes d1
knight takes the one
bishop knight takes h3 queen takes h3
and now take the pawn on f6 you don't
have a lot of pieces try to create any
sort of mating attack against my king on
g8 and actually after you do take on e6
the pawns are equal the material is
equal but your king on g1 just feels
much
worse than miking on g8 so i will have
to give the advantage to black in this
one instead of that
he played the move f takes e6 let's see
how this game continued rook takes d7
knight takes d7 bishop to e3 not taking
on uh e6 not capturing that pawn for
whatever reason allowing knight takes h3
rook to e8
c5 oh my goodness it's just double
question mark after double question mark
every single move knight to f6 bishop to
f2 queen to c8 still maintaining the
advantage for black bishop to d4 knight
to h7 this king is just too easy and
where did it go
knight to g5 that was the problem
the fork against the queen that was the
problem knight to e4 allowing bishop
takes e4 followed by knight to g5 and
well that just gives up the queen by the
way ray robson also climbing back into
contention on board five he won with
white the final move looks to be in the
illegal move i suspect it was one of
those time forfeitures where a player
reaches out but ray robson uh always a
force in american chess to be reckoned
with as he wins as well and if you do
have our uh leaders of swords just kind
of sort of like a role model i can guess
levon aronian and fabiano carrano have
four and a half from the six games that
they've played yes nobody else should
have reached four and a half but with
four points we should have
what was it five games
this is a round number five right guys
so four and a half out of five is darn
good four and a half out of five for
both of them only drawing against each
other then on four points i don't see
why am i missing people
oh martinez alcantara reaches four
points yep uh dominguez and sevien have
three and a half and typo doesn't reach
leslie i think with three and a half we
also have volusia yeah we have verusion
we have ray we have a ton of people with
three and a half countries but i think
with four
it's just
jose martinez i don't see anybody else
so two players tied for first yeah one
player in clear third
as we get ready for our sixth uh game
and that's true we have the standings
now fabiano and aronian four and a half
uh each uh jose martinez only is the
only one with four and with three and a
half we have arujian we have linear
dominguez sam sevian ray robson and
irina crush
[Music]
your thoughts thus far as we've kind of
reached the halfway of the tournament uh
christian i've seen this movie before
guys it's leveronian and fabiano caruana
just duking it out for the championship
uh they did that in the american cup
that just finished and fabiano uh got
that one but i have to say both fabiano
and lev are really impressive in uh this
event it just feels all right they're
overpowering their opponents and i think
the games are actually about to start
we'll start with board number one
between jose martinez alcantara and
levon and i want to give the youngster a
chance he's a student at webster
university he's currently at four out of
five he's a blitz specialist plays a ton
at chess.com under the nickname jospem
quite quite strong so we're gonna go to
board number one
yep jose martinez against
that one that we have right there the
other matchups we have for you fabiano
corona versus linear dominguez
sam savion against maurizio nacobian
irena crush against ray robbs and
gregory oparion against wesley so
jeffrey against robbie carefully spilly
and it keeps going down from there uh
tell our viewers a little bit about jose
martinez where is he from and which
school is he going to he is from peru he
is about 26 10 26 15 grand master very
very very strong peruvian grand master
absolutely and uh he goes to webster
university nice
so he's one of the understudies of liam
of likewise absolutely
he's always a chess coach a very active
uh streamer yeah he really is very
active on twitch he plays a lot on
chess.com as alejandro was mentioning
he has a lot of blitz experience in the
last couple of years at least very good
very different take over the usual
rui look closed rui lopez's as the
knight on c3 is not a common guest often
knight d2 to f1 to g3 here it can go
knight c3 to d5 added option as well as
knight c3 to e2 g3 kind of transposing
into
well-known territory
any particular reason why why this
um there's so many subtleties in the
spanish nowadays the the main thing is
that you're avoiding um
some some of the variations there were
black uh it goes for an early b4 against
a4 early a4s because you get 95 right
away like you see in this game
there are some ideas here i don't know
how dangerous they really are against
the player of levon's strength
by the way queen e8 what us
he wants to go king h85 you can almost
feel the fire of burning i mean because
that knight on f6 interferes with f7 f5
we've seen levon in such positions by
king h8 and knight g8 so knight takes d5
and queen e8 those were
instantaneous and two minutes 49 seconds
once again indicating
the great preparation of lavona rooney
you just can't disturb this guy this guy
has before enough prep to just throw it
around in blitz tournaments that's how
much prep he has right right and this is
one of the big advantages that the
players that were active uh during the
last couple of weeks in the american cup
have over these newcomers from the
universities they've been preparing
these lines for the past two weeks
intensely they're fresh yes
all of that uh
if you will theoretical knowledge is
just
bubbling uh
over after these last two weeks and it's
not a surprise that lavonne and fabi who
are really world-class grandmasters to
start with
coming after this
american cup are doing so well king h8
telegraphed i would say that f7 f5 is on
black's agenda but it's such a powerful
idea the telegraphed or not it's not
easy to see exactly what it's going to
do about it then the correct question
comes what is the problem with f5 you
can imagine that with a move like rookie
one you might want to take and go d4 or
d4 right away or d4 right away but lamar
is asking the question he doesn't see
any immediate tactical problem exactly
this is the way to develop c3 a bit slow
too slow for my taste but uh d c3 was uh
jose's of choice um
in these positions i don't mind defining
the
the uh structure structure with the move
uh f5 takes e4 we see that in that
yawnish gambit that kind of structures
not bad for black bishop f6 i like what
i like i like
knight
is coming g6 is coming after black's
play really i believe it just itself it
plays itself and yeah it's true i think
now you would love to play the move
bishop to e3 and uh follow it up after
knight to e7 with bishop a7
the problem is that four dragons start
with f4 yes that's a big problem you're
going backwards
okay 97. i think it's time right you go
97 no way the white takes on e5 and
takes on f5 that bishop on d5 is pinned
exactly no f4 he goes over even more
aggressive i would say that is a very
very aggressive move uh because you want
to play queen g6 and bishop h3 very
quickly there was a capture by jose on
e5 yeah if they can advantage the knight
takes e5 he does have bishop takes f4 or
does he whoa or what does he well bishop
what's the wrong with bishop f4
knight f3 there are some knights of
three bishop e5
and that's just
g5 is an idea as well that's amazing but
it doesn't look pretty well i win my
pawn back after g3 i can take on h3 uh
to begin with
jose saying okay okay you know
let's keep it under control a4
i hate it when i go b a4 and my opponent
just takes it okay well at least in this
case
now uh white has something to nibble on
the queen side bishop they see five
takes takes yeah i have three certainly
a threat here f4 f3 an enormous
positional threat do you play f3 and
king f1 i think perhaps i think you
you're forced to in fact but now you're
not getting the vote simply asks the
question how are you getting your palm
back thank you getting the part of that
pond yeah
we're gonna give him his gold medal
certificate for the pawn grubbers
society
as the pawn on a4 uh
makes bishop b5 also if the king ever
goes to f1 there could be a bishop b5
check that could into g6 he's focusing
white's king right now and again bishop
h3 on tap queen to g3 is also
a
a very very uh big discomfort and the
clock five seconds for jose martinez
he's just made his move with five
seconds left on the clock he needs to
start feeling the pressure on playing a
little faster exactly but it's i like
vision b5 c4 bishop d7 c6 c6 it's just a
strong threat i don't know what you do
about it five seconds to find out e5
check c5 you go back to g1 i think he
should have gone back the previous move
and not entombed his bishop
bishop c4 but now this allows queen to
g3 in certain instances
even queen e6 just
i'm upon grabbing all right take on c5
they go c5 also you take on v5 i take
with a pawn you have to play queen c5
now my structure has been
[Music]
transformed fixed thank you
fixed i couldn't think of the word
that's a good word it's a good word and
we're going back through it queen takes
c5 is forced but black is a pawn and
it's a good pawn now to do good
absolutely uh the pawn on a4 paul karas
remember your classics and
c takes d6 opening up the cc file
what a masterpiece what a masterpiece
and solving your problem live and this
is just desperation exactly you can even
take you guys like on g3 f4 bishop takes
f4
nobody's doing that nobody's defending
this pawn rook fade first is fine as
well of course of course
and there goes another pawn not
necessarily that's too many pawns yeah
and black will double i love how many
times it's played with one second left
but i don't think it's making it and he
resigns
let's go board number two between
fabiano caruana and lanier dominguez
they're still in a fight i spot that
fabi needs a win to keep pace with
lanier but he might be doing it with
this pawn all the way to e7 ready to
queen
and you've got a bishop on b5
controlling the promotion square looks
like fabi
has got this game in his pocket unless
no even queen takes e8 fabi's got this
game queen takes c8 was a big big big
threat queen takes f6 followed by rook
to d7
where why did he not play queen takes
oh because rook died was covered by the
twitter m600 a6 yeah i had the same like
uh
uh power to eight rook to g7 is a threat
but bishop to b5 and if rook g7 wrote
the ada doesn't have time to no this is
dead lost right precisely bishop to c4
oh that was that's mean
don't even take it
oh
you did take the rook but you didn't
even have to you're gonna play king g3
and i think i think you just go rook b7
you defend the pawn right of course rook
to c6
the greedy or the greedier c6
greed is good a4 no
takes f5 i mean right takes f6 is a big
threat h5 is taking all of those pawns
this is bobby's
vacuum cleaner just taking all of linear
spawns this is too easy for him exactly
this is too easy for him
to h5 cut the king
g4
you got no problem rook h5 you you just
bring the rook back to g3 get the king
yeah so that your king can cross the
third rank
this i mean linear knows it he's just
hoping for a miracle
and this looks like
well there's two people just unstoppable
yeah i mean what what's going on fabio
and levon are they're good blitz players
don't get me wrong but there's some
seriously wesley sauce in this
tournament and we're not even
remembering him right
and fabi are stealing this show
completely five and a half out of six
both of them that's possible both takes
f6 mates that's me
i agree they are nice what's going on
they are really they're on fire
i would see think by the judgment of
that expression it has somehow defeated
uh varacobian no he's one actually
who sam won san juan against far yeah
because of the shake and
the slight uh disgust there so at the
very least there's a full point
difference
between
levon
and fabi who sit at five and a half
and on four and a half we have sam
sevien right we have ray robson yep and
that's it wow uh you had mentioned at
the start of the show that arena you
know just outclassed her competition
that's just the way it was she was a
dominant force in the american cup 2020
to the women's section she really looked
like a class apart right now
that's what we're seeing in the blitz
we've got two players the finalists uh
of the american cup a class apart fabian
lavonne yeah
only giving up a draw against one
another that's insanity beating
everybody else pretty impressive stuff
christian what do you got for us well i
was looking at this game between oparin
and wesley saw because wesley saw seems
to have slowed down in the last couple
of games and in this one he was actually
on the worst end of this uh end game at
this point oparin decided to sacrifice
the pawn he got tempted by the idea of
infiltrating with the queen on f5 the
game continued c5
b takes e5 b takes e5 and now g4 we
understand oparin's idea he wants to go
queen to f5 get the king down the board
and then capture one of the pawns the
problem is that you already sacrificed
one of the pawns so you're only going to
get it back it's going to be an equal
position after that and this is exactly
what happened none of the players were
able to create much out of this
instead of that instead of this move c5
very tempting move by the way what he
should have done was to go g4 first the
same idea i want to go queen to f5 you
do have the queen better placed as black
you can stop me from doing that with the
move queen to e6 but this allows me to
later on create the past pawn with the
move c5 all i have to do is defend the
pawn on a g4 and in fact this king on h3
looks vulnerable but it's not because
there's no way you can attack it the
king cannot go back because i take on g5
the knight doesn't really have where to
go the only place to go is g6 but you're
not going to activate your knight from
g6 you would love to go knight to d7
somewhere uh and try to activate it like
that but unfortunately it doesn't work
because once you go on the other side
i'm going to infiltrate with the queen
on age seven that's how you're going to
lose so after knight to g6 all i have to
do is just lose a couple of tempes and
then at the right moment start pushing
my pawns create the past pawn get my
pieces in their right squares and the
position actually is quite difficult
perhaps even losing for black right now
thank you christian as we prepare for a
break uh we've we've gone through six
rounds aleandro they go fast to go
quickly we're done with round number six
we're gonna take a short break as we
enter the last third of the event uh
this is gonna be fast furious but it's
been a tale of two
players and that's
show fabio
we'll be back with it in a couple of
minutes don't go anywhere
[Music]
it's time for the return of the grand
chess tour featuring the world's best
players in some of the most unique
places across the globe romania poland
croatia and the united states join us in
may as we kick off the 2022 tour in
romania and then immediately followed by
poland this is your chance to see the
best players in the world's greatest
game follow all of the action live at
granchester.org
chess the smartest game on earth
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station
with a new mirror maze light shows and
the 20-story high st louis wheel it's
enough to make any parent feel like a
star st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
that's right show now go play yours at
reasonboat.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back and let's go straight into it
as we are moments away from starting the
seventh round of the american cup blitz
it is a show of two players and two
players only as lavona ronyan and
fabiano carrana show why they reached
the finals of the american cup they are
absolutely on fire five and a half out
of six in this split section this is
just scintillating they get two strong
opponents levon will be having the white
pieces against san sebian and fabiano
will have the black pieces against ray
robson you described it very well as
those two players are galloping away
from the field can sam savion slow down
this runaway horse of lavonne aronian
and ray robson
uh as we know from the american cup he
can tickle anybody uh he he upsets
uh lavon ironian in the classical game
that was very important to force a
playoff in the in their matchup but uh
sam savion started with a loss yes and
he's climbed all the way to table one
not bad in such a strong field yeah
absolutely he started with the last
and since then has bounced back
beautifully with four and a half out of
six currently he's going to face levon
he can catch him with a win and a win
he's going for with the sicilian defense
remember in whoa bishop c4 in blitz the
advantage of having white it's usually
not as strong as in classical chess
yeah and with this bishop c4 variation i
always like reverting to the b7 g6 kind
of dragon variation if white's not going
to play d4 i like having my bishop on g7
sam said no bishop b7 is fine with me
and let's keep it in the channels of a
sicilian b7 b6 inviting the move d4
right now yeah i love the set but d4
will be
met by a kind of a takes takes and maybe
a knight at d5
uh takes on e4 and then d5 and that's
why he drops the bishop to a2 now d4 is
on top exactly
with the e4 pawn
properly covered so for example rook c8
d4 is a possibility i also like this
idea of playing knight f1 to g3 for
white uh bringing the
bringing the knight especially after a
bishop a6 attacking the one on d3
because d3 d4 takes takes knight b4
could hit the d3 square hence
now one question uh after an i2f1 that
that could pose
is what do you do knight to e5 precisely
and that's exactly what he's about to do
uh we have a knight e5 on the board if
you take on e5 now you have to defend
somehow the pawn on d3 if you take e5
opening up the d-file i'm starting to
like blacken that yeah in those lines
where you take i like the move bishop b1
just defending everything playing knight
play for knight g3
play h3 bishop e3 and eventually one of
these days truly truly truly
uh d3 d4 will be played knight takes e i
think c5 now only after knight d7
opening the option for uh black to
change the pawn structure with what he
has done
does this move invite f4
and this seems to have surprised lev
who is right now taking a thing whereas
i thought
capturing with the e-pawn was
the correct move it seems to have
stopped love in its tracks somehow
whenever e5 what do you think about that
just whenever i see this pawn structure
um and whenever i have the option of
taking on e5 enforcing this change of
pawn structure i usually don't go for it
i feel like black has a very safe and
very solid control in the center as well
as the open d file that he can use to
enhance his uh his control i don't
disagree and i don't like the move f4 i
do not like the move f4 i much preferred
to move a5 if a5 if i can encourage b5 i
like the fact i'm taking away the attack
against the d3 pawn
now with the move bishop g5 you can see
that black is thinking trade a few
pieces plant my knight on the e5 square
and
focus on the backward d-pawn i'll be a
happy camper
bishop d6 i like this temple because
rookie 8 i can meet with the move e5
well i can also say a
tacit offer of a draw i thought in some
way right yeah bishop d6 will be a
repetition after bishop g5 and why not
[Music]
20 seconds behind on the clock but also
one point ahead in the beginning
against sam savion but he also has his
eyes on the game between fabiano and ray
robson that's an important clash as well
yeah just to tell our audience yes yes
yes should this game end in a repetition
we would immediately switch to board 2
and the game between ray robson and fabi
and
well this time in vancouver
guys not only has and
why
there's no choice right this is not
where you
don't take the drug exactly i mean not
when you're behind on the clock don't
say it twice alejandro because he's
going to play rook 28 and make a fool of
all of us
but now okay
we'll move on to the game number two
between ray robson and fabiano caruana
look at this magic of television hi dan
machuca as we have ray robson against
fabi in this position fabi is up a pawn
but it's a typical type of catalan
compensation for it so it's not
it's a very good bishop and a lot of
white
uh the energy of white's pieces are
focused
against that c6 pawn i can imagine the
rook coming to d1 angling for a bishop
f1 tactic yeah it feels like despite the
fact that black is up a pawn then maybe
white is the one that has dictating
the action for now
knight d5 a very solid move
and they're completely level on the time
well now they're going for ray rubs
huge success
success one minute exactly for ray one
minute and twelve for favi come on rook
d one plays itself you're threatening to
play bishop f1 he's going forward right
you can okay here up to f1 cure that
rook on the a6 square drive it back
which he has done
and now i'm thinking bishop f1 and
trying to control the c5 square like if
you go bishop f1 queen b7 queen c5
you're really posting up in the nicest
possible way it feels like we jinxed
right he he hasn't moved since we got
here
ray you got to move queen c5 first oh no
that spoils things uh
quite a bit in my estimation because
that really
does help black with his a pawn
um it's not the end of the world you'll
have threats of knight c4 you'll have
threats of rook fa1
let's let's see if this works out as we
have the even better shot here
this is much clearer actually
a4
all right just asking the question
is still a possibility i like rook c1
because now i can always take on c5 with
the roar i thought queen c5 was an
automatic but uh fabby paused
now he gave his opponent the option of
recapturing with the rook which he does
a little strange that's a logic glitch
going on there uh
you don't you think i think so yeah uh
okay but now again who is better in this
position also who has more time
they're completely even two no 23
seconds four seconds less for fabiano
right now uh not much between them as
far as the clock is concerned
rook to b8
bishop f3 sidestepping any problems on
the first round you just never know when
they come down on the board but i also
like bishop f3 because bishop d1 right
might pick up this baron a4 and actually
bishop d1 right now
doesn't that pick up well there is this
issue c4 not allowing the rook trait
i think roxy is just even more ambitious
i love it i like this move it's keeping
each other
one coming knight d7 knight c5 is going
to be an idea as well this pawn is dead
dead dead dead and you don't even have
to hurry we're taking on a4 you can go
with knight to d7
and rook takes a4 but now why not hurry
right the pawn on c6 is going to be
hanging at the end with the move wait
what can i not take fabiano is in
trouble now
b5 is before
no you cannot because you have rookie in
the end
yeah king g2 it's also a new move you
like to sneak in and he should have
knocked him before but still looks like
an advantage ray robson is pawn on a6
it's very weak
it's exactly take the point no question
about it uh thank the one thing later
right ray is
for sure d3 most likely is going to come
no rook 2 says fabiano don't play knight
takes before because knight takes e3
where is this counter play got coming
from he's trying to win it guys
to g7 takes d5
has to be played takes f2 some counter
play knight to f4 defend the important
h3 square no wait what's going on okay i
think it's one of those blitz
it's all about the clock now knight f4
it is a drawn position
uh on the board but i think oh black is
for choice fabiano definitely has a good
chance with that knight landing on f4 96
what a move
forcing the trades and
ray is going to make a draw
actually i'm not sure who's going to
make a draw but i'm sure it's going to
be drawn now
king e2 king takes and e4
king f4 oh sorry sorry sorry if rook was
hanging that would have been a little
bit embarrassing this is going to be an
easy draw yes it is
and we still we still have var playing
actually if uh this finishes up on board
number five g2
but it's not it's going to be king
versus king
very near while here and there's no need
christian maybe you can take us through
one of the other games sam beat oparin
that is jeffrey
beat misha antipov
wesley saw beat irena crush
and it looks like jose martinez is
coming back after his previous loss
he will be defeating varus nakobian
indeed he will
okay back over well as we just watched
these uh we have the last moments of
another game this is what we mean by the
vultures the vultures
whatever this what do we think about
can we no we don't we don't have the we
don't have the whole board by the way
for those of you who'd like to know the
man in black on the extreme left
grand master edward romine is a gm in
residence and uh
he's in here with a good look a bird's
eye view oh yeah and the game that is
going on is jamiljan and limarandi with
the black pieces on the left against
ilya nishnik on the right side with the
white pieces unfortunately we don't
actually know what's happening because
there are pieces on the queen side yeah
but all the vultures going around you
see operating on the right overlooking
the game we have a partial look we have
a partial look they got a full look at
and lanier hasn't moved right now
he's
about this game totally
there's a lot of stress going on and we
might not even figure out what the
result is
all i know is that this king is marching
forward there's a putter in e4 i think
it's passed
wesley for one has made a determination
of the outcome there's a pawn going down
the board
for both ilia and chamilchan actually
where is the white king is the question
that's the king on g3 i think that is a
king
and i think it's going to just end in a
draw yes i think that is the entire
position draw then between jamil general
nimrandi and ilya nizhnik what a funny
one i think that was the last
game of the round as my comer
international arbiter my comment is
making the pairings making the pairings
and making sure everything is
well done
one of the wonderful things today is
they have the software the swissy
software to make these pairings i
remember when i was playing in these
open events there'd be enormous
arguments as to like no i'm supposed to
play this other guy and that the pairing
is all wrong and nowadays there's just
nothing to discuss it's like here it is
i used to play opens before computers
could do pairings and they had this like
giant wall chart somebody had to do it
manually with like 15 different pens of
different colors they had the index
cards
those were fun days how about you uh
do you remember those days christian or
did you always have the company no no i
remember those days my dad is also an
arbiter so he used to make the pairings
with those cars that you guys were
mentioning
about but i do want to draw your
attention before we start the game
because they're moving fast the arbiters
are also moving fast they're they're
creating those pairings quite quickly so
this game between shanklin and oparin we
got to this position shanklin is with
the white pieces creating a very
menacing attack on the king side the
knight on g5 if it manages to land on f6
or h6 that's going to be all she wrote
completely dead for the black king with
the queen on c3 so now what black had to
do at this point is try to create some
sort of counter chances the one way to
do so
was to force this queen off the dark
square a1 to h8 diagonal with the move
rook to b8 follow it up with rook to b3
put some pressure on the queen of course
if you try to go h5 then rook to b3 this
is the problem that you have to face on
this side h5 h6 and checkmating threats
and now i'm just simply going to harass
if you go to f6 i'm going to harass the
queen with queen to d8 try to exchange
the queens and this would lead to a
better position for black in fact
he did not see this move very difficult
move to see
with only two minutes on the clock he
play this move rook eight v8 it just
feels like it's not the right direction
right you're going to get killed on this
side and exactly that happened h5 came
h6 and now a very beautiful concept by
sam shanklin take on g6 take on g5
g7 a missed move by his younger opponent
the rook on f8 is trapped not only that
but i actually have queen f6 queen h6
queen to a shade coming this is just
completely dead queen to f6 and sam
shanklin went on to win a beautiful game
after that quite a nice moment in that
particular case where black had to go
for the counter play
nice i i like uh the the finish
especially you don't just immediately
grab the rook on f8 you go queen six so
here we are on casual friday and
[Laughter]
what do you think guys is still uh two
horse race all right so what we got
levon and fabi move up to six out of
seven
ray and sam move to five out of seven
and then with four which ones who won uh
jeffrey jeffrey juan jeffrey one sam
shangri-la
one jose martinez won yes he did wesley
won and wesley wesley won but he doesn't
reach five out of seven because wesley
only have four and a half three and a
half so he reaches four and a half
out of uh out of seven points
and we have two more games remaining
two more rounds
two more rounds remaining and we don't
have pairings but it's always going to
be between boards one and two to start
we've been giving a lot of love to lavon
and uh perhaps
it depends upon
their opponents because
since we've seen lev
last game i think we should switch to
fabiano that's fair all right i got i
think i got the perry so i want to say
going to be on the second board which i
was also haven't given any love to shane
clinton exactly let's go for that let's
go for that fabian shanklin on board
number two will be
our uh key matchup and of course we'll
keep eye on eye out on uh levon please
jeffrey
that's a big one as well now jeffrey as
we know was so close to knocking fabby
uh
causing fabby to lose one of his lives
um essentially it was an armageddon game
jeffrey had the black pieces all he
needs to do is draw he has a winning
position
in a very language
uh his move and uh flags
gabby wins the match goes on to win the
american cup that's how it works in
chess it's the
battle of details really exactly and
again we are we're gonna be focusing on
board two
as sam shankland uh has fought his way
back
yeah i i
i haven't really
thought of sam shanklin as a real top
blitzer no but he's he has said that
he's done a lot of work on it and
he did lose that game against alcantara
which
christian showed us with this knight xf4
but he's back in the mix yes he is and
he has a good chance here with black
piece against fabio only two rounds
remaining so it's important for these
players at the top to keep adding police
but
also for those players you know point or
two behind saying this is my chance to
fully come back in the tournament and we
have uh the game started between fabi
and sam shanklin it's going to be
yeah maybe a semi-slab because of what
shanklin has been focusing on lately
e2 e36 semislav
has advertised b2b3
one of those move orders that whoa
knight e4 well that's definitely mixing
things up yeah
traditional knight d7 it's actually the
recommendation in his course 94. it's
chesable course yeah yeah and f5 at some
point very soon i like uh those chess
authors that practice what they preach
yes if you're going to say to everybody
go ahead and play knight e4 and you
don't do it yourself
it kind of sends a bad message that you
don't believe in what you're stating
and
a3
a3 bishop c3 bishop a5 is a funny little
maneuver like what what are you bringing
the rook to well i was about to say are
you bringing the rook to c2 uh
helping white of sorts wait what happens
if i pick up your the exchange no wait
the knight c3 knight c3 queen c2 tonight
takes a2 it's the bishop hits the bishop
he missed it i think he missed it i
think it's straight up missed it he just
blundered it next he brought her an
exchange he was expecting rooksy too oh
that's the knife was trapped he thought
the knight was trapped the bishop on c1
was hanging at the end precisely he
couldn't take
fabby could not capture the bishop on a5
as the knight on a2 would have captured
the bishop on c1 and
fabi who is cruising
right up into this moment has just
blundered in exchange his opponent has
as a materially winning position
well at least he took shankland out of
his opening point
finally right
a blundering in exchange will
tend to do that yeah but this is no
compensation no compensation the second
knight is coming to e4 now this is the
problem and that's going to open the way
for black to go g5 g4 and try to
checkmate white's king and any of these
trades
of the pawns merely opens up the
position actually
for the rooks the rooks will eventually
come into play bishop d6
it stops bishop f8 95 immediately
and
fabi's doing his best to try to get some
compensation as he staked the claim stay
in the game and stay in the game in the
center within the move 95.
i like what he's doing because right now
after the exchange of dark square
bishops at least that knight on e5 is
going to have a beautiful outpost for
the remainder of the game okay so bishop
a3 queen a3 bishop d7 no
says
sam we can trade dark square bishops but
i don't want you to have your queen on
the a3 diagonal so let's try it fabiano
says are you going to follow it up with
c5 i'm thinking rook b1 just because
or f4
do you ever want to go f4 you probably
do in this position normally no but
you're down the exchange i'm not here
but you're right he did please close
things up let's go f4
maybe he's gonna go for a five
a5 and if we can put the pawn on he's
going tonight to f3 the bishop dc where
is that going
it came
in good timing not a big fan of this
move knight to f3 for fabiano c1 don't
understand that move bishop to e8
looking at the h5 square as well as
knight to d7 to exchange the knights but
it feels like white's gotten a lot in
the queen side and black hasn't made a
lot of progress well
now's the time right don't you want to
put your work on b8 and play for
a6
a6 yeah rook to b8 and a6 and he trades
opens up the b file bishop h5 but okay
big big big tickle alert on the but now
i can exchange on c6 go queen to b7 and
perhaps oh no
so let's get the rook to b1 that's what
i was saying
i have no idea guys that's but by the
way
what what what
he wants to go a five eight six creating
he wants to say five a6 and create a
passport that's not a bad idea i don't i
don't even know if white's works
a5 you have to be careful about any sort
of uh knight moves because that's going
to attack the knight on g5 knight to e4
comes on the board and now do you go
back to f3 or do you exchange on e4
no if you go back to f3 you do allow
bishop takes f3 the rook will come back
to if anything if anything knight h3 but
that also seems very ugly i think
i like knight h i don't think it's ugly
at all in fact if i could just please
dear lord let me put my knight on f4 i
will be a happy
big threat
a6 usually
what is this against the threat
by the way
opportunity to capture i i like it with
the knight i i really do like the
tonight you could set up knight a5
that's the thing queen b7 knight a5
looks extremely bad guys fabiano right
now is searching surging is out playing
his opponent from a losing position out
of the opening truly it feels like it
didn't matter that he was on the
exchange he's completely winning right
yeah exactly i mean this pawn on b6 is
absolutely enormous knight f4 is a
gorgeous positional
trump for white
and move 10 and then just wins easily
exactly get sam shanklin out of the
opening and then go on to win a smooth
game wow b7 knight f4 all of these moves
are coming with tempo possibly even
including f3 no punch robbers
association very good hitting yet again
the training and it's not just upon the
knight is coming now to d3 and joining
the fray via e5 i like queen before i
like the way it's not the only move no
it's the it's it's it's
good that kills it
right there it's control right there and
then lovely queen then you get to play
rook c7 bring the knight back
yeah i think the knight has to go back
to c4 just to prevent the conclusion you
are absolutely right that is in fact
what is
and then you drop the other knight to
asap now it's time to invade
i think it's knight c6 here roxy7 is
fine too
rook to c6 followed by knight rook to
seven followed by knight to c6 this is
all she wrote
wow play on one goal from losing an
exchange to just dominating thereafter
perhaps even remarkable game five now i
really like knight c5 knight c6 isn't
bad
everything wins just to mention the
obvious guys knight c6 you're gonna go
back now you go f3 and knight c5 or
and just to give you a heads up of what
we're about to see jeffrey shang is
taking over the initiative against
leveroni
to board number one
board one as we have lavon
with the white pieces against jeffrey
shawn let's take a look at what's
happening in the position as we move
ilia nishnik out of the shot
physically
yeah he's 2700. thank you
and here what's going on uh extra pawn
for jeffrey and a worse structure for
lavon four seconds for level two
that pawn is coming to meet you wait
wait oh oh
what's going on right now because he
right now he might be losing
no yes he might no
i think he just blundered his entire
position what a turn of events guys from
winning easy to completely losing
in three moves all right what's the
final count he's down upon his jeffrey
right somehow oh but he's got his pawn
on h3 i thought he lost his h-pawn he
lost his first stage he has two h pawns
he gets another one i understand all
right this end game is lost three verses
well why why h2 is coming perhaps not
anymore
h2 is coming and at some point f5 has to
be played no definitely
five rookie five so rook d1
i don't
[Music]
get up
so rookie eight right no this has to be
losing
i'm not sure
yeah king g6 has to be g6
rook to e7 and now f5 is a threat
no no once again rookie six no f5 f5
rookie six
king of seven drop
perhaps that was the moment
with a cut kingdom
king to d4 king come penetrate oh dc d6
that's easy d6 is too easy wow what a
turnover what
that is terrible i mean when we
picked up that board
but we still have some games going on
right now guys one of them is about to
finish so perhaps on board six but i
think that one just finished as we were
talking yeah
how did
our two tournament leaders just had
great fortune the both of them as we
thought fabi blundered in exchange
very little compensation and then it
became a one-way street then lavone
ironian when we came to the game jeffrey
was just dominating what the heck
did he do
we saw something we saw this structure
all right yeah everything is right okay
black stuff and now
and winning and winning yeah and then
somehow okay
somehow this is the moment guys after
king to g7
okay
seven okay king g2 queen f5 rook to a7
yep now that move shocker of a move h4
came on the board
just simply forgetting that the rook on
c4 can move laterally but still at this
point you're still a little bit better
with white uh partly with black but then
suddenly he starts losing it's unclear
after h4 i mean the pawns are equal i
think it's so easy anymore yeah but now
suddenly white is
two pawn no nope one pawn up and then
lavon went on to win this game uh quite
the turnaround
uh up to this
moment both abby and lavonne were
winning their games by playing well
here they both got very lucky that's
good enough because they both find
themselves with seven points out of it
that's not updated don't worry about it
seven points out of eight sunshine
simple score lost ray robson lost
they've been they got pushed down that
good push down sam sevilla lost to
wesley so everybody got pushed down
wesley goes to five and a half out of
seven martinez alcantara
is actually eight sorry out of eight
jose martinez alcantara on six out of
eight he proves to be an extremely good
blitz player okay i think he would be
winning the tournament except for
you know these two guys these monsters
yeah unesco dominguez
quesada making a huge comeback so
basically has
the two players locked
first and second uh no
we don't first of all we don't know
which one gets first and second but also
jose martinez can catch them
with the win and both of them have to
lose yeah
oh boy what else uh have we
missed in this very eventful round uh
christian i was looking at the game
between sam savion and wesley so the
surging
wesley saw on five and a half out of
eight right now in this position it
seems like sam savion is in full control
all he has to do is just open up the
avenue for the queen to get to h5
your pieces a lot of them at least are
boxing on the other side of the board
you don't have enough defenders and
knight to h4 seems to have been just
easily winning queen to h5 is coming on
the board and you simply don't have
enough time to get everything uh back to
the defense of the king instead of that
he lost a beat with a move queen to c2
wrong direction and after e4 we have
this position
and queen to d5 allowing white to grab a
pawn on the other side but at least
bringing and solidifying my position on
the king side as black this is exactly
what
wesley so wanted to see queen to d1 back
to the fray back to h5 no no more queen
h5 your way allowed quinto h5 queen to
f6
take take take
that's going to be a piece to the good
for black
sure but i'm coming to checkmate you
right now root to g3 and this is finito
no no no wesley says queen to h7 check
out this defense boxing the king to h8
and after queen to g5 rook to f5
actually your attack is simply over oh
then
wesley went on to win with an extra
piece beautiful defense by wesley so and
that takes down sam savion who was
simply unlucky in this game what a
turnaround what what the nation's
defense thereby wesley wow wow and the
all-important
ninth and final round pairing will be
coming up uh do we have a guess as to
who is going to compete against fabby
fabi must play martinez
there's no other choice on that one no
choice
i think that one has to play wesley
exactly yeah i think that's absolutely
forced as well now in the american cup
lavonne actually knocked out wesley in
the elimination bracket right that's
right with the black faces and a
beautiful game with two oh oh there they
are
vultures over the standings over the
last round pairings they want to see
where they're gonna finish their
tournament exactly exactly
by the way we had spoken a few uh a
number of times about arena crush is she
still in the mix or is she dropped down
this is such a strong tournament let me
take a look let's take a look at some of
the standings we have fabi levon and
jose martinez those are the one two
three very clear wesley is clear fourth
then with five points we have shanklin
dominguez and robson xiong and my
student aksha chandra
yes sir yeah yeah baby four and a half
we have a kobe and kevlary oparin
with four we have satonski alimorandi
burke theodoru with three and a half
unfortunately a little bit stuck uh
irina crush so liquid benjamin gladura
raja harshid ilya nishnik rapka i really
got the feeling that the russians
started strong but not the stamina yeah
the young
guy yeah yeah did i just hear casada
wasn't he on zero out of three yes zero
now he's on four and a half he started
off he started with zero out of three
got a bye then won three in a row yes
and drew against lanier domingue wow
i mean it's almost uh it almost feels
like a uh
we
come back for the ages except for the
fact that we have a runaway on tables
one and two which we will be focused
upon
look at this match up wesley it's wesley
against levon but we're going to have to
give favi some screen time here
simply because i want to see jose
martinez a player
so where do we go we got the number two
it's jose martinez alcantara with the
white pieces he lost to levon earlier in
the tournament but that was pretty much
it because he's had a bounce back of
an incredible bounce back he lost to
satonski
and he lost to aroniana and he hasn't
lost to anybody else wow beating
everybody else we we will focus on uh
the board number two match with fabi
having black
as will lavonna aronian also having
black against wesley so i'm also i'm
also not sure why they're playing on
board too but this is a question for a
different
because martinez has more points than
wesley so they should be playing on
board one but whatever but levon has the
higher doesn't matter you you switch it
out yeah or whatever
here we go uh once again a little
insight is to the background of fabi's
opponent if i was upon us young i
believe he's 20 maybe 21.
a long time ago i remember those days
peruvian 26 plus it's about 3 000 rating
on chess.com wow
yeah there's a lot of blitz monsters
here okay and super super active
streamer and very tricky extremely
tactical tactically tricky
okay we're looking for a sparkling
tactical brilliancy
uh to finish off this ninth and final
round and the american cup blitz he's
repeating the variation that he played
against levon now fabio plays it without
the move b5 which is a very big twist it
does change the character of the
position because with this move c2 c3
any b5 will allow the option of bishop
c2 now and of course we'll be keeping an
eye on the wesley game against levon but
this is going to be our focus
all very standard up to this point
uh the fianchetto bishop kind of
discourages the knight from ever getting
to g3 as the pawn on
g6 stops that rook e8
quite flexible
now we're probably going to see some
knight d2 knight to f1 maneuver coming
from white and there we go and you
called it b5 bishop to c2
b5 bishop b3 would encourage knight a5
that's why you're hiding the bishop out
on
c2 but now black says hey look if you're
going to give me a free hand in the
center i'll play d65 maybe on a good day
i'll even go further with d5 d4 we'll
see how it breaks
normally don't you play a4 here you okay
a4 you play kind of automatically yeah
right you kind of want to have that
option of opening b3
square
that's a twist i've never seen this idea
because the 90's usually already exactly
but knight b3 does intimate that bishop
comes to e3 the knight could come to c5
with or without a4 with a4 of course
but a5 and
a very uh important question where are
you going to put the knight fabby saying
your knight on c5 doesn't disturb me so
in that case now after advancing my
queen side
bishop
taking control of the district
square waiting for the bishop to jump to
b7 or a6 to attack it with knight to c5
exactly i like the movie rook ba just
put your broken what's eventually going
to become at the open field the open
file and it's a bit of a passing move
i'm not sure what white's next move is
immediately maybe just queen e2 queen d2
just connecting the rooks but i do like
what you're saying and the other problem
is if you play a desirable move bishop
a6 bishop e6 knight c5
give alejandro the love rugby
again nimsovich did have some great
witticisms one of his was the mysterious
rook move oh that was target
turrish gets
gets um
everything but he didn't say any of it i
think this was a [ __ ] but i could
easily be mistaken rooksy one in any
case is the mysterious move if the move
rook b8 was planning to take advantage
of the open b file maybe the move rook
c1 made more sense yeah it was planning
to take
advantage of the open c file didn't
happen guess what guys the b file got
open and maybe it's time to put the root
back
on b1 and just to give you an update on
the wesley versus aeronium game that one
is still very tense and a very balanced
no advantage going on there knight comes
back to d2
i like it i like it by uh
jose martinez he's keeping everything
under control
and again he's thinking that i'll
challenge on the b-file bishop f8 by
fabio i like it i like bishop effect i
don't like this thing
one
30 seconds
time that's a lot 30 seconds 40 seconds
right now and climbing eight six six
clearly not sure what to do
but it feels a little uncertain the
bishop could also bounce back
out to b3 by the way but i do like
starting with the move rook b1 maybe on
a good day i'll play rook b5 but bishop
b3 on the board bishop e6
put the rook on b1
please
open files he likes that rook c1 move
come on coach
hey none of ours
uh oh uh the time
you know they're evening out how the
times get spent you know it's sometimes
it's a real mystery because this is not
a position where there's any tactical
things going on what are you just
careful about d4 yes sir maybe not
especially i'll take of course i get the
bishop to f4 but
yeah well come on queen c2 rook b1
move
no none of that sure i like that move
knight takes
and now that's a very strange decision
yeah because it did a lot larry to hit
the bishop on e3 is weird
yeah he wants to play bishop b5 i can
certainly uh applaud him for that type
of effort but taking on e3 taking on c4
bishop could come to c5 that might be a
weakness suddenly making an appearance
on the d3 square but the knight of c4
would be pretty good attacks a5 attacks
e5
and the queen will come to d5 for for
for black how do you continue the attack
right now you go
i'm thinking knight e3
rookie 3 bishop f5 bishop c5 i apologize
bishop c5 maybe rook b2 when you're not
looking we should take c4 knight takes c
but the 9 on c4 is just always going to
be guarding this rook v2 i like the
knight on c4 i understand that the
bishop on c5 is scary right but i don't
think what i don't think why it's worse
and this creates an immediate threat e4
that's why queen
defends indirectly knight on c4 yes so
bishop d5 will be made with d4 i don't
know hold on hold on hold on bishop c5
what happened after bishop c5 d4
e8 is saying of course of course of
course sorry that's why fabiano plays
bishop to g7 reinforcing the defense of
the important e5 pawn
okay rook e6 perhaps
finally wait a minute
does that give up a pawn or are we
headed no because if you take and i take
a question three there's rookie no but
rookie eight i take cake
so okay that's okay yeah rookie rook
takes e8
takes e1
a5 has oh this looks like a draw
rook queen takes d3 rook takes d3 rook
takes a5 or queen takes d3 rook takes d3
rook c5 both our draws are both heading
to a draw
and that wesley is putting up some
pressure on levon and we'll see that
after these players are done with their
match
so he goes for the professional way he
wants to just play rook b2 rook a2
exactly no not give white any chances
exactly and he's the first one to
pressure that tender f2 square so rook
e3 perhaps rookie no then you go check
and you pick
one on f2
so i will have to take on a5 i think
just take on c7 and just make the draw
oh yeah 10 seconds for alcantara come on
let's go rook b2 rook f1
okay d2 rook c4
rook c2
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa what was wrong that was a
confusing move
uh i think you're giving too much right
chances suddenly like why who's trying
for a win right now it's black
black is definitely playing for an upper
hand here a3 what's wrong
i think he's looking at rook check i
mean this is still objective
three
this is
very weird allowing the point
rook check to see three the king has to
go to f4
why do you even play this what happened
in the wesley game i've been told that
it's just that was a draw actually if
bobby wins this which i don't know how
he's going to do that but he has chances
why that check i thought rook c3 there
are some chances guys
that's going to be met by check
and rookie d5 king d5 what did wha what
was this who's going for a win it's
crazy i think white is suddenly i don't
know anymore
oh kingdom oh he tries to make a draw no
and a draw agreed between
caruana i don't actually know the
objective evaluation of this game but we
are being told that wesley saw the one
iranian drew their game let's go and
then to board number three as linear
dominguez is playing ray robson let's
see if we can catch a glimpse of that as
players are fighting actually we have a
surprise money
yeah for prize money exactly uh rook
a what is going on here it feels that
white is just totally winning right
correct black is getting bigger d6 yeah
made it
whoa
i think we're seeing a repetition
it was nice
how did he make that how did he make
that physically
and i think that's it yeah queen h3
picks up a queen that's
and that is pretty easy
dominguez defeats robson and
moves to six out of nine a very
respectable score robson absolutely well
don't forget big fight by robson right
now going to b6 going to pick up the
rook and that's it that lanier finds one
of previous world blitz champion is our
linear dominguez
and uh what an eventful round uh that we
ended up let's tie for first we still
have there's another game going for
number six but i don't know if we have
that one
unfortunately
gregory gregory oppain is playing as
robbie kepler's village and it might
have been over already no they're still
playing you can see them on the right
but it's over don't worry about that one
that one is over but that one is going
to be a win for robin kevlish philly who
actually wait how many points does
robbie have
well it really feels like our tournament
winners kind of stumbled across the
finish line it
is in the last two rounds penultimate
right right it's very suspicious some
lovely uh but they did it they did it so
fabi and levon win the tournament this
is a tie for first place we have no tie
breaks here uh time for first place
let's play a playoff exactly you know
you don't have to convince me you have
to come use the producers and the
players and the players i think the
players the players would be okay with
that no i think the players are like
cher first is nice you know it's been a
it's a slow it's a casual friday all
right so what does happen favi gets
first lavon gets first jose martinez
dies first third no
he clinches third it's gonna be third
place for jose martinez alcantara what a
success for this youngster really what
what a success for this youngster how
did he six and a half out of nine was he
always in the top or did he well let's
let's see what he did he beats the
rulato aquito in round one okay then he
lost to satonski
then
he beat talia cervantes
then he beat it's all ladies
he beat robert kevlish billy okay then
he beat sam shanklin then he lost to
levon
he beat varujon
beat ray robson and he drew fabi
that's so successful
wow that's a good event that's playing
against the olympic team there i died
for first place if we needed to give
this man more money well we are 4 500
extra dollars for fabiano carona and
another 4 500 going also to levona ronin
as they tie for first place a very
successful two weeks to both of these
gentlemen congratulations to our winners
yeah but what about a runner-up player
once again a clear third clear third
goes to jose martinez
i'm sure the production crew was
going crazy what happens if this guy
wouldn't have no picture exactly exactly
well that's what happened
and uh well uh wow where's the
tournament christian your thoughts as we
gather our own well it was a great event
guys casual friday i think we should
keep this for the broadcast as well as
perhaps have this type of blitz event on
a weekly basis i really like seeing all
these youngsters bringing so much energy
so many good vibes to the table and just
giving us a show and as always guys
always a pleasure to cast all the games
with youtube well for us we'll say the
same uh we'll we'll be in direct
communication with you christian as you
go to bucharest and we get ready for the
grand chess tour we close the curtain on
the american cup but we open it for the
grand chess store absolutely safe flight
christian as you go to romania let's
perhaps remind the viewers that we have
the jesus what's coming up coming up
just a few more days mary third we have
the opening ceremony of bucharest
romania but may 5th we will have the
very first move made for the grand chess
tour of this year you can look at it
over there bucharest it will be our
first stop it's a classical chess event
may 3rd through the 15th missed in
immediately afterwards we'll have the
super bad rapid and blitz may 17 to the
24th
we have as the chess world in general a
small break in june for the candidates
to happen and we will come back in july
just before the olympiad starts we will
have magnus carlsen joining the gct for
our rapping and blitz and croatia and
then we come back for the rapid and
blitz here in st list and finishing off
with the marquee sink field cup and i
have a prediction for zagreb
it's going to be a great event
i'm going to get that in before you do
thank you everybody for sharing your day
with us i hope you enjoyed the blitz
championship we'll wish you a wonderful
weekend absolutely we'll see you next
week bye from st louis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited